bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne deux auditions consacrées
à l'avenir de l'industrie automobile les
sénateurs ont entendu mardi Denis Martin
il est le directeur général de PSA
peugeotit R et il a d'ailleurs indiqué
devant les sénateurs que son groupe
était réellement confronté à une
situation difficile en 2012 avec de
mauvaises perspectives sur le marché
européen je vous propose donc tout de
suite d'écouter son audition je rappelle
pour mes chers collègues que Monsieur
Denis Martin est à la fois directeur
industriel mais
aussi que je me trompe pas dans vos
titres monsieur le directeur responsable
des relation soci relations sociales au
sein du groupe PSA bon Monsieur le
Directeur
euh au carré j'allais dire par des
formation de physicien une double
casquette que vous avez le march le
pardon le marché mondial automobile est
en pleine recomposition avec en
particulier l'arrivée des pays
émergentss mais à la fois en
consommateur mais aussi en producteur en
plus il y a des rythm de de croissance
qui sont très con contrast décevant les
rides selon les zones de
consommation quelque chose qui vous fera
peut-être moins plaisir Monsieur le
Directeur c'est des constructeurs
français de moins en moins liés au
territoire national je fais cours mais
on y reviendra tout à l'heure c'est sûr
la parole sera à la défense un rôle
d'entraînement encore fort pour
l'économie française h ça existe et
c'est pas en présence de sénateur du dou
et du côté de Montbelliard que je dis
ces choses-là c'est un rôle
d'entraînement encore fort pour
l'économie française malgré des signes
qui peuvent être inquiétants sur pour
l'avenir et enfin globalement un point
économique relativement décroissant de
l'industrie automobile dans le PIB mais
dans l'industrie d'autre part d'une
façon générale voilà Monsieur le
Directeur l'ensemble des choses je suis
persuadé que vous allez nous parler un
peu de votre groupe mais ensuite de
l'avenir de l'industrie automobile en
France telle que vous la voyez merci
vous avez la parole bouton
rouge très bien monsieur le Président
merci pour cette introduction mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs issu de de plus de de siècles
comme vous le savez d'une aventure
industrielle née en France PSA Peugeot
Citroën c'est un grand groupe automobile
européen c'est le numéro 2 en Europe deè
constructeur présent dans 60 pays dans
le monde nous avons vendu sur l'année
2011 plus de 3500000 véhicules élément
détachés alors pour entrer monsieur le
Président d'emblé dans le vif du sujet
je vais vous proposer de dire tout
d'abord quelques mots des principaux
axes stratégiques de PSA Peugeot Citroën
en premier lieu nous nous sommes fixés
je ferai un lien avec ces axes
stratégiques bien évidemment avec la
politique industrielle française et
notre vie de constructeur automobile
français en premier lieu nous nous
sommes fixés pour tout d'abord pour but
d'accélérer notre projection sur les
marchés mondiaux ça veut dire nous
projeter et de manière beaucoup plus
forte en Asie en Chine particulièrement
et puis vers l'Amérique latine vers la
Russie et c'est-à-dire vers des zones de
marché sur lesquelles se concentrent au
jour d'aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la
croissance mondiale de la demande
automobile actuellement mais également
et et on le sait pour de nombreuses
années cet effort passe en particulier
par des implantations d'unité de
production nous produisons là où nous
vendons sur ces grands marchés comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs en Chine mais
également au Brésil ou en Argentine et
désormais en Russie alors permettez-moi
d'affirmer ici très haut et très fort
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
notre volonté et de poursuivre et
d'accélérer notre développement sur les
marchés mondiaux et que cela ça ne
correspond en aucune façon à un
quelconque complot en délocalisation qui
serait ourdi par PSA ça doit être simple
ça doit être bien entendu il n'en est
absolument pas question nous produisons
là où nous vendons et il représente tout
simplement pour nous un impératif vital
parce que les marchés
européens le marché domestique le marché
européen c'est aujourd'hui un marché
sursaturé totalement mat
et qui est marqué essentiellement par du
renouvellement c'est aussi un moyen
important pour nous de sécuriser
l'avenir du groupe et l'avenir de nos
usines en France et je vais vous donner
un exemple très simple puisque je le
connais bien ayant été moi-même
directeur de Rennes c'est la Peugeot 308
508 pardon qui est produite à Rennes au
au nombre de 135000 unités mais
également que l'on vient compléter avec
une production de 65000 unités de ces
mêmes 508 en Chine produite à Uran pour
le marché chinois ainsi en faisant et en
ayant cette stratégie industrielle nous
allongeons nos séries nous donnons plus
de visibilité à notre production en
Bretagne à Rennes de ce véhicule haut de
gamme nous nous sommes assignés comme
objectif de parvenir à un pourcentage de
50 % de nos
ventes mondial hors d'Europe et nous la
atteindront en 2015 et cette voie sur
laquelle nous progressons nous permet là
aussi d'enraciner encore plus
profondément et je vais m'en expliquer
nos attaches en matière de recherche et
développement et en matière de
savoir-faire au niveau indusriel en
France ce qu'il faut se rappeler c'est
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir d'avenir pour
un constructeur généraliste qui ne sera
implanté qu'en Europe si nous n'étions
que cela nous sommes condamnés et vous
le savez donc nous sommes condamnés à
devenir un constructeur
mondial c'est le premier axe de notre
stratégie devenir un constructeur
mondial le deuxième axe c'est d'assurer
progressivement notre montée en gamme de
nos produits et de nos organes mécanique
dans le total de nos ventes je rappelle
quand même que la part de nos véhicules
de ce que l'on appelle du segment B tel
que la Peugeot 207 ou la Citroën C3
représente 45 % des volumes contre 33 %
sur la moyenne du marché ce sont des
véhicules qui sont riches en tout cas ce
que ceux que nous faisons en contenu et
ainsi en sera de la nouvelle Peugeot 208
sur laquelle nous fondons d'énormes
espoirs et qui va être produite et vous
le savez tout d'abord à poissie et puis
ensuite elle sera faite également à
mulouse et qui démarge et qui dégage ces
véhicules là tout de même une marge
limitée et donc nous devons absolument
équilibrer notre mix de produits en le
tirant vers le haut c'est-à-dire avec
des véhicules à plus forte valeur
ajoutée hein et à plus forte prestation
et meilleure rentabilité alors c'est
tout l'enjeu pour nous de l'effort de
monter en gamme et c'est ce que nous
avons fait depuis quelques années avec
les lignes distinctives DS je parlerai
de la DS3 qui est faite à poissie de la
DS4 qui est faite à mulouse et de la
nouvelle DS5 qui est faite à ce choud et
qui sera bientôt proposé en version
hybride c'est aussi le cas de la Peugeot
RCZ de la Peugeot 508 et qui aura
bientôt également une version hybride
donc nous progressons régulièrement sur
ce terrain puisque la part de ce que
nous appelons des produits premium dans
le total de nos ventes est passé de 9 %
en 2009 à 13 % en 2010 et à ce jour est
à plus de 18 % en tout cas pour nos
Vendes de 2011 montter en gamme c'est
une stratégie gagnante à long terme pour
le devenir de nos usines en Europe et
particulièrement en France on parle
souvent de l'Allemagne mais vous voyez
nous sommes capables de faire des
véhicules Premium en France et depuis la
France et à contrario il faut le savoir
que de ne pas monter en gamme c'est de
se condamner à être présent dans des
régions low cost de et dans les sols
produits à bas cout monter en gamme
c'est également je le rappelle c'est
protéger nous protéger du déclin de
notreingéerie c'est protéger nos
savoir-faire et protéger nos talents
dans le cadre du développement de nos
organes je vais donner juste un
éclairage PSA s'est positionné
résolument sur le terrain du véhicule
hybride c'est-à-dire celui qui combine
les avantages écologiques de l'énergie
électrique avec les possibilités de de
mobilité qu'offrent les technologies les
plus pointu de motorisation
thermique avec la Peugeot 3008 hybride 4
la DS5 hybride 4 et bientôt la Peugeot
RHX nous nous nous serons et nous sommes
aujourd'hui le premier à proposer des
véhicules hybrides diesel lancés dans le
monde nous avons été appelés d'ailleurs
à saisir les pouvoirs publics à la fin
de l'année dernière sur la question du
maintien du dispositif d'incitation à
l'achat de ce type de véhicule par les
flottes d'entreprise lesquels jouent de
plus en plus d'ailleurs un rôle
déterminant dans le décollage d'une
technologie nouvelle permettez-moi de
souligner ici au Sénat que notre
démarche a reçu une écoute très
attentive et je voudrais en remercier
particulièrement vos collègues monsieur
Martial Bourquin ainsi que Madame
Valérie destard et Madame Fabienne
Keller retenez aussi que PSA présent sur
le véhicule tout électrique et toujours
aussi en pointe dans le domaine des
progrès des moteurs thermiques classique
réalisé dont l'ingénierie dont les
développements sont en France et dont le
dernier fleuron est le moteur à essence
B 3 cylindres lancé récemment en
fabrication à trémerie en mzel et que
nous verrons bientôt en EB atmo à
Française de Mécanique à Douvrin je
voudrais maintenant consacrer la
deuxième partie de mon propos au
problématique industrielle et sociale de
PSA Peugeot
Citroën ces problématiques sont au cœur
de des deux autres de nos axes
stratégique c'est-à-dire la volonté
d'atteindre l'excellence
opérationnelle et la volonté d'être en
tout point un groupe
responsable il s'agit pas seulement de
dire il faut des usines en France il
faut des usines compétitives et des
usines responsables et je vais vous
donner quelques ordres de
grandeur qui permettent d'appréhender la
réalité et la profondeur de l'ancrage du
groupe PSA en France et monsieur le
Président excusez-moi de vous contredire
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit dans
votre introduction je vous rappelle que
le groupe rassemble plus de 200000
salariés de par le monde dont 100000 en
France avec 60000 emplois directs dans
nos
usines en France nous sommes l'un des
tout premiers parmi les acteurs
industriels opérant sur le territoire
national avec 6 usines terminales 11
usines de mécanique et d'organe nous
produisons 44 % de notre production
mondiale de voiturees en France mais
aussi 85 % de nos moteurs de nos boîtes
de vitesse et de nos pièces
mécaniques ces chiffres sont importants
pour bien appréhender une réalité qui
n'est pas toujours bien connue en
particulier par de nombreux acteurs du
débat public c'est en France que PSA a
maintenu son socle technologique et le
maintien et le
maintiendra et c'est en France que PSA
maintient tout son savoir tous ses
talents et sa base
industrielle cette réalité c'est pas le
fait du hasard mais le fruit d'une
volonté constante manifesté par toutes
les générations de dirigeants à travers
l'histoire contemporaine du groupe PSA
retenez que PSA modernise constamment
ses usines en France nous avons dépensé
près de 2 milliards d'euros en
investissement sur l'ensemble de nos
sites depuis
2008 cet effort se traduit par des
progrès constants réalisés par les
salariés en matière de
productivité cela se traduit également
par des avancées spectaculaires qui sont
réalisées par les salariés en matière de
qualité des produits automobiles de PSA
qui n'ont plus rien à envier au produits
allemands
comparabl ce qui est en jeu ici c'est
d'atteindre et ce que nous partageons
avec Philippe Varin président du
directeur du groupe PSA ce que nous
appelons l'usine excellente c'est-à-dire
un appareil de production aligné sur les
meilleurs référentiels mondiaux qui sont
déjà en place dans nos usines en matière
d'organisation d'innovation industrielle
nombre de nos usines ont déjà sur
certains de leurs domaines atteint ces
meilleurs standards mondiaux et notre
ambition est de les porter dans dans
l'ensemble de nos sites sur tous les
aspects
ainsi l'élimination de cause de
variabilité l'augmentation de
l'utilisation de nos équipements
conduisent à l'obtention d'indicateurs
industriels de premier plan tout à fait
comparable avec les
meilleurs mondiaux et souvent on peut
les trouver dans nos
usines et je tiens à rappeler que cela
aussi conduit à ce qu'en matière de
sécurité depuis 3 ans nous atteignons
sur certaines de nos usines le zéro
accident pour nous les critères de
réussite sont exigeants l'augmentation
du taux d'utilisation de nos équipements
la réduction du nombre d'heures par
véhicule la réduction des pens d'énergie
par véhicule produit hein et la
réduction des surfaces affectées à la
production mais pour autant et malgré
tous ces progrès qui ont été réalisés il
est essentiel de prendre conscience de
ce que l'équation économique de la
production industrielle d'automobile
dans un pays comme la France devient de
plus en plus problématique et plusieurs
facteurs se combinent pour expliquer
cette évolution très préoccupante le
premier facteur l'existence de forte
surcapacités structurelle en Europe dans
le domaine des véhicules d'entrée de
gamme et de moyenne gamme les petits
véhicules de type je vais citer Citroën
C3 mais aussi également Peugeot 207 mais
que l'on peut trouver dans la
concurrence comme la Clio la Twingo
l'Ibiza l'Audi A1 la classa et cetera
tout cela prend une place de plus en
plus importante et surabondante dans
l'offre automobile en Europe de ce que
nous appelons dans notre jargon les
segments A et
B PSA produit une large part de ses
véhicules dit du segment B sur le
territoire
national mais pour leur part nos
concurrents produisent leur véhicules du
même segment B excepté un seul dans le
pourtour ou en périphérie de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire dans des pays où les coûts
industriels sont très inférieurs à ceux
qui existent en France une offre de ce
type de véhicule sur le marché européen
depuis la Corée désormais depuis l'Inde
où sont implantés des constructeurs tels
que Suzuki nician Hundai puis bientôt
depuis le Maroc sont des offres
extrêmement agressives face à nos
produits made in France l'existence de
force surcapacité structurelle déjà
présente en Europe sur ce segment touche
tous les constructeurs et une conséquen
très concrètes sur un marché à très
faible croissance donc comme celui de
l'Union européenne une intense guerre
des prix un constant laminage des marges
avec toute la destruction de valeur qui
en découle en particul en terme de
compétitivité des sites qui sont
concernés et donc la question qui se
pose est la suivante comment assurer la
viabilité des sites les plus touchés par
un contexte à la fois structurellement
surcapacitaire et durablement
déprimé c'est une vraie question une
question qu'on ne peut éluder car si on
ne veut pas la regarder en face toute
façon la réalité un jour nous rattrapera
et vous le savez bien dans le métier de
l'industrie automobile il existe un
paramètre qui est pour nous
incontournable c'est le taux
d'utilisation des équipements
industriels qu'on appelle encore le taux
Harbour et on considère généralement que
sur la base de trois équipes le taux
optimal en Europe est d'environ 120 % à
ce jour sachez que nos usine PSA du mois
de janvier je vous donne les chiffres
que j'ai eu hier le taux d'utilisation
est de 80 % 80 % de notre taux
d'utilisation en Europe ça signifie que
nombreux de nos ne tourn pas au plein de
leur capacité loin de là et que leurs
coup fixes ne sont pas suffisamment
amortis afin de limiter les effets
négatifs de cette situation nous avons
et vous le savez mis en œuvre des
mesures fortes d'organisation
industrielle des
compactages de nos usines de manière à
optimiser leur fonctionnement sur des
espaces plus restreints simplifier
rationaliser l'ensemble de nos process
nos flux mutualiser les
moyens nous avons conduit un certain
nombre de mesures mesur aujourd'hui qui
étaient en tout cas qui se sont imposé
au cours de ces dernières années le
deuxième facteur qui doit être pris
également en compte tient à
l'aggravation de l'environnement
économique général de l'industrie
automobile en Europe pendant l'année
2007 c'estàdire avant la crise violente
qui s'est produite à la fin de 2008 il
se vendait en Europe plus de 16 millions
de véhicules 16 millions de véhicules en
Europe aujourd'hui le marché européen
plafonne à 13,6 millions c'est-à-dire
que par rapport à son niveau d'avant la
crise de 2008 il a baissé de 15 % et
beaucoup de signes aujourd'hui nous
permettent de penser que nous sommes
encore très loin de retrouver les
volumes d'avant-crise et
vraisemblablement pas avant 2020 en tout
cas aujourd'hui avec les données qui
sont les nôtres au cours de l'année 2011
l'environnement s'est à nouveau dégradé
le marché automobile européen
globalement en baisse de 0,6 % sur
lesquels nous réalisons
traditionnellement nos meilleures
performances il faut le savoir que ces
marchés-là ont connu des des chutes
historiquement vertigineuse c'est
particulièrement le cas du marché
espagnol - 17 % le marché italien - 10,5
%. donc résultat les ventes du groupe
ont reculé en Europe de 6,8 % en 2011 en
particulier sur le segment B alors
qu'elles tiennent plutôt mieux sur les
segments supérieur grâce notamment au
succès de la DS4 au lancement de la
Peugeot 508 alors l'année 2012 s'annonce
avec les mêmes difficultés sur le marché
européen et PSA se trouve confronter à
une situation devenue réellement plus
difficile alors qu'il nous faut
absolument préserver nos ressources et
les moyens nécessaires à les réalisation
de nos ambitions pour cela conformément
aux valeurs et la tradition de
responsabilité sociale du groupe nous
avons pris dès l'automne 2011 des
mesures d'adaptation comme vous le savez
qui ont été certes décrié mais quand on
en connaît le cœur la vérité nous avons
dit les choses et nous avons cherché à
préserver le plus possible nos moyens de
manière à être capable d'affronter
monter la conjoncture actuelle notre
démarche n'est pas celle d'un plan
social ça a consisté à identifier des
métiers sensibl ou excédenta ainsi que
les métiers entention en développement
et d'organiser toutes les mobilités
internes ou externes permettant de
réaliser toutes les adaptations
nécessaire c'est ce que nous avons mis
en œuvre c'est un ensemble de mesures de
mobilité qui permettent de conduire les
salariés vers des métiers en
développement ou d'organiser les
démarches de formation
d'accompagnement et de supprimer les
postes par attrition naturelle j'insiste
sur un point essentiel une des clés de
notre politique industrielle elle a
résidé dans la capacité de nos salariés
avec les partenairires sociaux et les
responsables de l'entreprise à tous les
échelons de se mettre autour d'une table
et d'inventer ensemble des solutions le
plus en amont possible c'est pourquoi
m'appuyant sur mon expérience
personnelle je veux ici affirmer ma
conviction forte que le dialogue social
se situe au cœur du combat pour la cause
de
l'industrie parmi les nombreuses accord
que PSA a signé au cours de ces
dernières années je citerai plus
particulièrement l'accord de 2010 sur la
gestion prévisionnelle de l'emploi et
des compétence que nous appelons
nouvelle dynamique de l'emploi au sein
du groupe qui est un modèle du genre car
il intègre l'idée d'une anticipation
collective des évolutions économiques et
sociales qui affectent l'entreprise
quelle entreprise aujourd'hui n'aura pas
de changement n'aura pas de
bouleversement toutes les entreprises en
connaîtront parce que le marché bouge
parce que le marché évolue et donc on
s'est mis dans ces dispositions là dès
2010 pourquoi le faire alors que nous
étions en pleine période plutôt de
croissance et bien nous nous avons su
l'anticiper grâce à des partenaires
sociaux là aussi qui ont su s'asseoir et
se mettre à table avec nous pour
dialoguer et anticiper le plus possible
ces mesures ce dialogue social pour nous
c'est le fait de partager avec tous nos
partenaires sociaux dans l'entreprise
les constats les analyses de fond sur
lesquelles s'appuie nos décisions et
dans la période difficile que nous
traversons nous sommes très attentifs et
je sais que vous y serez sensible au
maintien de la qualité de notre relation
sur les territoires avec l'ensemble des
sous-traitants sur
l'ensemble de la filière ainsi qu'à la
constance de notre action en faveur du
renforcement de la filière automobile en
France Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs permettez-moi de
vous
livrer modeste conclusion en tout cas
quelques convictions fortes qui sont en
quelque sorte la profession de foi d'un
groupe industriel qui est
viscéralement fidèle à son ancrage
français mais aussi la profession de
foi modestement de moi qui est plus de
32 années d'expérience professionnelle
sur le terrain industriel dans la
conduite des hommes dans les
usines maintenir la place de PSA peugeoc
Citroën dans le tissu industriel
français c'est un combat de tous les
jours c'est un combat difficile mais
c'est un combat au combien passionnant
compte tenu de notre environnement
concurrentiel mouvant dans lesquel nous
évoluons nous faisons des produits
merveilleux des produits exceptionnels
et dans ce combat le principal atout de
l'entreprise c'est sa richesse humaine
les quelques c000 hommes et femmes du
groupe PSA en France dont plus de 80000
dans la seule division automobile en
France c'est notre richesse c'est la
richesse du groupe j' ajouterai un
crédau qui m'est personnel j'ai la
conviction et de la responsabilité
majeure d'une entreprise comme la nôtre
dans le domaine de l'intégration des
jeunes génération leur accueil leur
accompagnement leur tutorat ainsi que la
transmission des savoirs par les seniors
en 2010 nous avons cuueilli 2820 jeunes
je vais vous arrendir les chiffres dont
2500 jeunes en alternance parmi lesquels
1650 étaient en contrat d'apprentissage
et de toute nature desbac pro jusqu'au
diplôme d'ingénieur voire même certains
certains diplômes de spécialisation
au-delà de des diplômes d'ingénieur dont
800 étent en contrat de
professionnalisation je n'ai pas encore
les statistiques définitives de 2011
mais l'effort consenti est du même
niveau et nous continuerons et dans le
mêême ordre d'idée je souhaite
développer en liaison avec plusieurs
territoires en France des initiatives de
en matière de formation industrielle car
l'un des enjeux de notre industrie est
d'y attirer de jeunes talents à tous
niveaux
l'une des clés de la compétitivité c'est
le développement permanent des
compétences la présence des centres de
recherche et développement le
développement des jeunes le
développement des compétences pendant
toute la partie professionnelle de la
vie professionnelle le développement de
l'apprentissage dans l'entreprise le
développement de la formation
industrielle et l'ouverture économique
c'est pour moi la première clé l'autre
clé de ce combat réside dans la capacité
de l'entreprise à faire évoluer
rapidement son organisation industrielle
je vous ai parlé de nos usines et de la
Recherche d'atteindre l'excellence dans
nos usines mais c'est aussi d'avoir des
organisations adaptées à nos usines ça
veut dire de la flexibilité de l'agilité
et de la souplesse cela veut dire de la
mobilité professionnelle et géographique
de la capacité d'adaptation de notre
système industriel à l'évolution de la
demande du marché ainsi en
2011 plus de 5000 collaborateurs en
France ont accepté une mobilité
professionnelle dont plus de 1300 une
mobilité géographique ce n'est pas connu
mais ce sont des chiffres vrais ce sont
des chiffres de tous les jours à cet
égard moi je rends hommage à tous les
salariés des différents sites de PSA qui
au cours de ces dernières années ont
accepté de rejoindre définitivement ou
temporairement un autre site du groupe
qui était en période plus favorable que
le le site dont il venait dans le
casadre de organisation qui sont
toujours difficiles à conduire cette
exigence de flexibilité est également
vitale car on peut se demander quelle
organisation industrielle pourrait dans
le monde
incertain qui est le nôtre demeurer
immuable et rigide tandis que à
l'extérieur les marchés les circuits
commerciaux et les produits évolue à
grande vitesse la mise en place de
crédit d'Ur de banque d'Ur ainsi que le
développement des équipes variable nous
permett d'adapter avec souplesse et
efficacité notre dispositif industriel à
l'évolution rapide de la
demande nous ne oublions jamais de nos
usines l'intérêt l'importance du client
il nous faut poursuivre dans cette voie
et mettre en place des contrats de
projet adapter à l'intégration des
jeunes sans qualification sur une durée
de 3 5 ou 8 ans ce sont des formations
des expériences solides
ceux qui ont été formés dans le monde de
l'automobile le savent leur
employabilité le capital de compétenence
qu'ils ont pu acquérir est immense face
à un monde incertain enfin et pour
terminer la troisème clé est- celle des
charges qui pèsent sur le coût du
travail je sais que le Sénat s'est
penché sur ce sujet en particulier avec
au travers des travaux qui ont été menés
par Monsieur Bourquin et Monsieur
Châtillon dans le cadre d'une récente
mission d'information sur la D
industrialisation des territoires je
suis sûr que vous y serez à nouveau
attentif car vous avez le souci de ne
pas pénaliser l'entreprise France mais
au contraire de lui apporter pardà vos
convictions les moyens de retrouver la
compétitivité dont nous avons bien
besoin c'est
pourquoi je voudrais dire notre
satisfaction de voir émerger un débat
public national sur la question de la
compétitivité de l'industrie
ce débat est utile il est indispensable
et il doit permettre à chacun de prendre
conscience de l'extrême difficulté qui
aujourd'hui celle du beau et passionnant
métier d'industriel métier qui est à la
base de création de valeur pour notre
pays je vous remercie de votre attention
et je me tiens prêt à répondre à toutes
vos
questions
merci j'ai déjà deux demandes de prise
de parole monsieur filleel
oui Monsieur le Directeur vous
avez dit beaucoup de choses avec avec
force vous avez très peu parlé de la de
la
sous-traitance votre groupe est un
groupe responsable nous sommes certains
en même temps vous n'avez pas étendu
votre responsabilité à l'accompagnement
des entreprises de sous-traitan qui
malheureusement pour beaucoup d'entre
elles ont quitté le territoire national
et sont partis dans dans d'autres
d'autres comme le Maghreb moi j'ai
l'exemple dans ma dans mon secteur dans
enentouren d'entreprise performante qui
ont quitté le le sol le sol local pour
aller s'implanter en Tunisie voire au
Maroc j'ai en tête par exemple une
entreprise au sellerie automobile qui
était un un donneur d'ordre
extraordinaire grande qualité du
personnel qualifié et voilà tout le
monde est parti l'entreprise n'existe
plus et le l'accompagnement de votre
groupe par rapport au sous-traitants
c'est le même cas d'ailleurs de pour
Renault je poserai la question à votre à
partir de 18h je pense que vous avez
peut-être pas été suffisamment attentif
à ce ce terrain extrêmement productif de
PMI PME qui vous accompagnent et qui
aujourd'hui ont disparu sur le
territoire
national merci je je me demandais si
Monsieur Bourquin était encore en route
pour nous rejoindre mais il ne m'avait
pas demandé la parole je lui donne tout
de suite parce que et ensuite la
priorité évidemment à Monsieur Châtillon
puisqu'ils ont travaillé ensemble sur ce
fameux rapport même si je n'ai pu que
les accompagner partiellement mais en
particulier très une mission très
instructive en Allemagne dont on nous
rebat les oreilles en permanence on
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
là-dessus monsieur Bourquin vous avez la
parole monsieur le le directeur j'ai
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
votre pladoyer et notamment les les
grands axes de celui-ci c'est-à-dire euh
la volonté de devenir un constructeur
mondial la deuxè chose monter en gamme
3e chose les responsabilités sociales du
groupe hein euh la volonté aussi
d'aborder les questions du coût du
travail je voudrais Monsieur le
Directeur vous dire que la nation
soutient sonent ses entreprises
automobile lorsqu'en pleine crise la
production s'est effondrée 6,5 milliard
de prêts remboursés en 3 ans qui ont été
remboursés de façon anticipée ont été
fait au constructeur automobile ils ont
été remboursés depuis avec 715 millions
d'intérêts il y a eu 900 millions de
prêts
AUO pour des PME qui ont NT bénéficié
qui avaient besoin de ces prêts il y a
eu 12 milliards d'euros pour la prime à
la casse
2,3 milliard d'euros pour les bonus
écologiques et surtout la part
importante du gâteau c'est que il y a eu
plusieurs milliards concernant la fin de
la taxe professionnelle
et c'est un investissement massif de la
nation en retour parce que il y a eu un
pacte automobile signé avec l'État on
est en train de faire le le les comptes
est-ce que la nation a bien investi
quels sont les retours en emploi
quels sont les retours en
relocalisation quelle est la balance du
commerce extérieur concernant
l'industrie automobile et là voyez-vous
euh dans la note de conjoncture dont
parlait notre président tout à l'heure
euh pour la première fois depuis
quelques années le solde du commerce
extérieur concernant l'industrie
automobile est déficitaire donc euh y
compris nos deux constructeurs euh
réortent des produits si bien que nous
avons une balance déficitaire alors je
sais bien que inévitablement faut pas
mettre les deux constructeurs ensemble
parce que un constructeur entre 34 et 38
% de sa production sur le sol national
comme disait Monsieur Martin tout à
l'heure un autre que nous aurons tout à
l'heure à entre 18 et 20 % de sa
production sur le sol national je
signale quand même que Volkswagen a 55 %
de sa production sur le sol national
donc ce sont des questions fortes pour
nous la question que je voudrais vous
poser
Monsieur le Directeur c'est quand une
nation investit autant dans son
industrie automobile qui a autant d'être
publique il y a l'obligation de résultat
en emploi l'obligation de résultat en
relocalisation et que le territoire
national soit investi par nos
constructeurs s'il n'y avait pas eu
l'état imaginez-vous voir lorsqu'il y a
eu cette crise terrible terrible où on
seraiit nos deux constructeurs
aujourd'hui ils ont ont su faire appel à
l'état qui était là et là lorsque ces
aides ont été données sur les banc de la
majorité comme de l'opposition on savait
qu'il fallait aider nos constructeurs et
on l'a fait simplement je prends un
exemple je j'ai là l'audit du cabinet
d'expert concernant les amortisseurs je
trouve et je vous l'ai dit je vous l'ai
écrit et je l'ai écrit à à Monsieur
Varin je trouve dommageable que les
amortisseurs de PSA
soit bientôt fabriqué en Espagne et le
cabinet d'experts de CFI nous montre
vous nous donnerez des explication parce
que j'aimerais les avoir que les l'écart
de compétitivité est vraiment
infime mais par contre ça représente 600
emplois sur ce Chud ça
représente des des emplois très
importants et chez les sous-traitants
des emplois aussi très importants donc
ce qu'il faut
et je finis parce que mon président me
demande de le faire monsieur Monsieur le
Directeur la la France investit beaucoup
on est en droit d'avoir un retour sur
emploi moi je suis dans un bassin
d'emploi qui est très touché par la
crise où il y a beaucoup d'intérimaires
qui ont été parfois remerciés où
maintenant ces remerciements touche
maintenant y compris des des cadres il y
a
concernant la stratégie de PSA depuis la
l'annonce des suppression d'emploi
massive il y a une vaste interrogation
et le plaidoyer que vous a fait tout à
l'heure doit se concrétiser par des
actes précis il doit y avoir des
relocalisations sur le territoire
national il doit y avoir des
relocalisations alors vous abordez le
prix du travail le coût du travail nous
étions avec le président de la
commission qui était à côté de moi en
Allemagne dans le bas duber qui nous ont
dit
entre une entreprise allemande et une
entreprise française le coût du travail
est à peu près le même et comment se
fait-il les Allemands on choisi de
monter en gamme ils ont Moné en gamme
peut-être qu'on avait pris un retard
làdessus et ça c'est vrai mais
concernant le coût du travail il n'est
pas plus bas en Allemagne qu'en France
il est un peu près pareil et plusieurs
organismes statisti nous disent qu'il
est un peu près le même et pourtant il
relocalis et il
embauch
j'essaie d'équilibrer les prises de
parole oui Monsieur le Directeur moi
j'isinroger sur la stratégie produit de
votre
groupe vous savez aussi bien que nous et
aussi bien que moi en tout cas
que c'est par l'innovation et par le
développement aval à forte valeur
ajoutée que effectivement on va créer
cette valeur nécessaire pour assurer le
développement et notamment de
l'emploi quand on regarde le marché des
même si je le connais assez mal je n'ai
pas si je connais l'aéronautique un
petit peu mieux c'est parce qu'elle est
localisée chez moi mais je reviendrai
sur le deè deè point mais est-ce que les
constructeurs français ont fait l'effort
nécessaire pour apporter une plus grande
valeur ajoutée sur les grosses
cylindrées et les produits à forte
valeur ajoutée où les Allemands
aujourd'hui avec Volkswagen Audi
Mercedes sont meilleurs que nous et la
question que je me pose c'est pourquoi
eston resté sur les produits assez bas
de gamme et pourquoi n'a-t-on pas réussi
sur les produits haut de gamme est-ce un
problème
de d'achat par les Français de
crédibilité de sécurité du produit voilà
une question que je me
pose la deuxième question c'est je
rejoins un petit peu ce qu'a dit mon
Martial Bourquin quand je regarde ce qui
se passe dans
l'aéronautique comme quand je je regarde
ce que font les industriels allemands
dans leur domaine
si nous voulons avoir une présence à
l'international il y a deux conditions
la première c'est qu'on est un navire
amiral par branche d'activité nous
l'avons dans
l'aéronautique est-ce que nous l'avons
dans l'automobile je ne le crois pas
ceci pour tirer nos sous-traitants et
aller là aussi vers la valeur ajoutée ça
c'est un point qui me paraît très
important parce que si on n pas ce navir
amiral comment pourra-t-on faire même si
si je comprends très bien que pour avoir
et tenir des marchés à l'étranger il
faut une implantation locale il faut une
implantation locale je le dis à certains
de mes collègues pourquoi je l'ai vécu
moi-même dans mon métier et dans
l'agroalimentaire si vous n'êtes pas si
N buvardez pas les attentes du
consommateur par une présence locale
vous n'avez pas la conquête des marchés
et donc je crois certes à l'exportation
mais je crois à l'internationalisation
des activités et puis le troisème point
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la pyramide
des vous avez dans votre entreprise
aujourd'hui voilà je m'arrête là parce
qu'il faut être
court
merci Monsieur
kaltenb Merci j'adère complètement au
propos de mon collègue Bourquin sur
l'emploi industriel et les bassins
d'emploi de socho qui sont très impactés
par les décisions prises par vos
entreprise mais je voudrais insister
plus particulièrement sur la recherche
et développement puisque lors du comité
d'entreprise 15 novembre 2011 vous avez
annoncé la suppression de plus de 6800
postes en Europe 5000 en France et il y
a 1000 emplois qui sont concerné en
île-de-fance ma région dont 400 sur le
site de la Garine colombe dans les
hautes scèes qui est mon département moi
je considère que c TR cette
restructuration dans le département des
haut de scèes est doublement
symbolique parce que c'est la première
de cette ampleur mais surtout c'est la
première fois qu'un grand groupe
automobile frappe la recherche et le
développement la recherche et
développement jusqu'ici si
épargné par rapport aux usines où les
dégraissages et les délocalisations
étaient monnaie courante alors bien que
la direction du groupe PSA s'en défendre
je constate qu'on assiste à une
délocalisation de fête des cerveaux PSA
a ouvert des centres de recherche et
développement au Brésil et en Chine
inauguré en 2008 le China tech Center de
Shanghai va passer de 450 à 1000
salariés une fois cette taille critique
atteinte il est probable qu'il commence
à travailler sur les modèles chinois
bien sûr mais également sur les voitures
européennes je considère aussi que ce
plan sonne aussi comme un désaveux de la
politique qui esté depuis quelques
années où on a massivement subventionné
la recherche et développement via le
coûteux crédit impôt recherche 5,3
milliards d'euros en 2012 et PSA on a
été un gros bénéficiaire et en échange
de ces efforts importants de la nation
on voit que malheureusement des emplois
de de chercheurs vont être sacrifiés
alors moi je pose ma question vraiment
sur le site de la Garen colombe quelles
sont précisément les cons du plan
d'économie de PSA sur le site de la
Garen colombe et les nombreuses
entreprises
s-raitantesition et avez êtes-vous en
mesure de fournir des garanties sur la
pérennité de l'activité de ce
site merci
euh madame Didier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur j'ai une question enfin je
moi aussi je m'associe au propos tenu
par mon collègue Bourquin je trouve
qu'il a brossé un tableau assez complet
qui qui dit bien la réalité des choses
vous avez insisté sur la la partie
dialogue social je voudrais euh vous
vous demandz ce que vous envisagez pour
le site d'OL net sous bois nous avons si
j'ai mes mes sources sont sont bonnes là
nous arrivons en fin de vie du C3
et et donc jusque quand ce modèle
sera-t-il exploité et est-ce que nous
aurons le nouveau C3
exploité sur place à H donc est-ce que
on prendra la suite sur les mêmes
chaînes ou est-ce que vous envisagez une
délocalisation pour la production de
cette
nouvelle
voiture merci pour finir la première
premier groupe de demande de parole
madame archambau
oui Monsieur le Directeur je suis
justement sénatrice de
et j'avais la même question que ma
collègue parce que nous sommes un
certain nombre d'élus de parlementaires
à avoir été euh alertés euh quel est
l'avenir du site d'lenet sous-bois euh
qui emploie si mes informations sont
bonnes 3300 personnes pour la scè
saint-is c'est considérable c'est
considérable vous connaissez la
situation de notre territoire euh c'est
3000 emplois 3300 emplois directs mais
il y a des sous-traitants c'est en tout
environ 10000 emplois et euh en effet
nous n'avons pas de visibilité sur vos
objectif vos prévisions après 2014
c'est-à-dire après la fin de la
C3 je voulais vous dire que nous sommes
un certain nombre d'élus locaux et de
parlementaires de ce
département prêt à travailler avec vous
vous avez indiqué qu'il fallait
anticiper euh parce que c'est pas pour a
possible pour nous d'envisager
d'envisager 3300 licentiements
supplémentaires de ancienne s
euh je rejoins également les les
questions posées par d'autres collègues
euh quel est dans vos efforts de
recherche développement la la part que
vous faites à la recherche de de de de
nouveaux produits vous nous avez indiqué
que si j'ai bien compris en en Europe il
y avait saturation du marché
deautomobile donc n'y a-t-il pas de de
de de nouveaux produits aussi à à
imaginer pour votre groupe en tout cas
je voulais vous dire que
euh notre inquiétude est grande et que
nous
souhaiterions non seulement avoir les
informations mais nous mais nous mais
nous impliquer en tant qu'élu avec votre
groupe éventuellement travailler avec
vous parce que c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est pour nous très inquiétant les les
les les les les disons les rumeurs qui
circulent merci Monsieur le Directeur
vous avez la parole j'allais dire la
parole est à la défense parce que j'ai
bien compris qu'il y avait un certain
nombre d'interrogations concernant des
sites c'est tout à fait classique dans
ce genre d'audition mais ça me rappelle
l'audition de Monsieur Pépi qui s'est
transformé en chqu ambulant l'autre jour
il répondait gare par gare au problèm
mais ceci éant dit je comprends les
préoccupations des élus locaux mais il
s'agit aussi de la stratégie
industrielle globale Monsieur le
Directeur vous avez la
parole je je je vais me permettre de de
de répondre par la par la dernière
question et les deux dernières
interventions parce qu'elle me semble
tout à fait justifiée et je pense que au
regarde de l'inquiétude qui peut être la
vôtre et qui est la nôtre hein on va pas
on va pas vous le cacher d'ailleurs dans
mon propos nous n'avons pas caché les
problèmes qui existe qui ne sont pas
ceux de PSA qui existent dans le monde
de l'automobile en Europe sur le segment
A et B donc dont les les les produits B
que enfin segment B produits que nous
fabriquons à heny à poissie à mulouse à
Madrid je vous le rappelle en Europe de
l'Ouest nous sommes nous constructeurs
français à avoir trois usines quatre
systèmes de production quatre systèmes
de production de montage à produire du
segment B j'ai entendu récemment
beaucoup avec beaucoup d'éloquence sur
un constructeur d'une autre marque qui
produit du segment B en France mais en
dehors de ça qui en produit donc je
pense que ne nous faites pas un faux
procès notre vrai problème qu'il faut
regarder avec vous c'est comment traiter
le problème parce que le problème il est
là il est celui de PSA mais il est aussi
celui de beaucoup de constructeurs de le
problème de la surcapacité c'est ce que
je viens de vous dire donc ce problème-
là nous l'abordons là aussi avec
beaucoup de visibilité beaucoup
d'éclairage et nous le faisons avec les
élus d'entreprise il y a beaucoup de
rumeurs il y a beaucoup de bruit soit
moi je sais de quoi je parle et et je
sais avec qui on le partage on le
partage avec les organisations syndicale
du groupe dans un comité stratégique
nous avons fait jusqu'à présent deux
réunions sur ce sujet-là sur le segment
B nous en avons une prochaine fin
février particulièrement sur les sujets
financiers du segment B et justement sur
la non rentabilité particulière du
segment B surtout en Europe de l'Ouest
et particulièrement en France que nous
allons aborder donc les sujets on les
aborde on les traite avec nos
partenaires c'est quand même la chose la
plus importante mais bien évidemment on
est tout à fait ouvert à vous à vous
recevoir ou ou moi-même aller aller vous
voir bien bien au contraire l'inquiétude
elle est elle est réelle mais en même
temps moi je vous réponds clairement et
d'ailleurs il y a il y a peu de temps
j'ai été amené à voir le maire d'olenis
nous n'avons aucune intention de vendre
nos terrains à henis contrairement à ce
que au bruit qui ont couru et nous avons
d'ailleurs et nous travaillons sur
toutes les solutions qui sont possibles
à heny et ailleurs je veux pas me
concentrer sur hnaet heny c'est un sujet
mais d'autres sujets existent aussi au
sein du groupe je veux quand même
rappeler au demeurant au jour
d'aujourd'hui
la situation d'Enet au jour
d'aujourd'hui oui on a on a quelques
journées de chômage oui on a une semaine
d'arrêt très prochainement qui qui tombe
sur la période de février on essaie
d'aménager les choses pour que les
parents ça puisse arranger les choses
alors les gens imaginent tout un tas de
trucs on essaie de faire bien pour que
pour que les familles puissent
s'organiser je rappelle quand même que
notre usine à baderd en Espagne chume un
jour sur deux qui s'en occupe qui s'en
préoccupe je peux vous dire que pour moi
c'est une préoccupation première bien
avant heny alors à heny il y en a qui
crient à feu et à 100 parce qu'il
préférait la révolution qu'autre chose
mais moi je dis qu'effectivement nous
avons un problème global de production
des des voitures du segment A et B parce
qu'elles ne sont pas compétitives quand
on les produit en Europe de l'Ouest or
qu'est-ce qu'on fait si on nous avons
choisi de faire la 208 à poissie nous
avons résolument choisi effectivement
parce que nous avons pu le faire à heny
de réduire la production il y avait de
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'un seul
système donc ce qui a pu donner une
viabilité économique en tout cas qu'on
essaie de tenir à poissi ce n'est pas
possible l'usine est est faite elle est
historique comme chacun de sait elle est
construite telle qu'elle est faite donc
on n' pas pu effectivement réduire cette
usine cette usine a énormément souffert
donc personne aussi s'inquiète h n'a pas
chôumé pendant la période 2008-
200009 je le rappelle quand même poissi
on a chôé 3
mois quand on faisait la 1007 c'était la
calamité bon aujourd'hui par chance nous
avons un produit qui est un grand succès
qui est DS3 sur une ligne à poiss et sur
une autre ligne nous lançons 208 nous
allons faire tout le haut de gamme de la
208 à poiss voilà donc on essae au fil
du temps de trouver des solutions elles
sont pas simples à HN oui on a un
problème mais j'ai aussi un problème à
Madrid mais j'ai aussi un problème à
mulose parce que il y a certains qui
m'ont d'ailleurs très facilement qui
m'ont demandé de faire ce qu'on
envisageait de faire à Mulous de le
faire à heny je veux bien enfin j'ai
aussi un problème mulouse enfin c'est
déshabiller Pierre pour habiller Paul et
cetera le problème c'est le marché c'est
le marché et sur ce marché nous sommes
attaqués essentiellement par des
produits qui ne sont pas faits en Europe
de l'ouest ils sont faits où ils sont
faits dans des pays Bakou voir très
prochainement en Afrique du Nord et et
et et essentiellement en Europe de l'Est
voire encore encore plus loin en Inde et
en Corée faut se le
rappeler donc voilà voilà la situation
mais je comprends votre inquiétude et
nous nous y répondons en tout cas nous
essayons bon certains il leur fait
plaisir d'allumer des feux moi je crois
que notre responsabilité est de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
de travailler aussi avec les
responsables publics et avec les élus
que vous êtes et c'est effectivement de
vous apporter le plus le plus simple des
éclairages possibles c'est ce que nous
avons essayons de faire un sujet que
vous n'avez pas abordé mais madame
lettard le connaît très bien c'est le
sujet de
sével sujet cével c'est pareil qui est
accablé PSA pourquoi parce que PSA est
en France parce que PSA reste en France
mais qui nous a quitté qui ne fait plus
le véhicule monospace familial avec nous
bon notre notre coopérant qui était avec
nous il a arrêté bon il a décidé
d'arrêter nous avons reclassé l'ensemble
des salariés personne n'en a entendu
parler il y avait quand même 250
personnes il y a 2 ans nous les
avonsclassé tous à valencien dans notre
usine mécanique nous continuons nous la
production de ce véhicule monospace nous
produ nousons la production des
véhicules utilitaires et actuellement
nous travaillons je peux vous dire et
c'est ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
pour moi l'industrie c'est pas du blabla
nous travaillons là aussi en
concertation mais principalement avec
les hommes et les femmes de sével pour
travailler sur la compétitivité parce
que nous avons fait une étude si ce
véhicule le véhicule futur nous le
fabriquerions à Vigo il peut-être
compétitif alors qu'est-ce qu'il nous
faut faire dans notre usine de Vigo qui
est une de nos usines les plus
importantes et historiques aussi au
niveau du groupe tout aussi ancienne que
beaucoup de nos usines que nous avons en
France dont nous nous préoccupons mais
qui est très compétitive et qui est qui
est à Vigo en Espagne donc nous avons
regardé qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire
en France pour être aussi compétitif et
je je peux vous dire que les hommes et
les femmes accompagnés avec toutes les
équipes techniques ont travaille
actuellement mais mais vraiment
fortement pour trouver les solutions de
compétitivité pour avoir le futur
véhicule à sesvell et on s'y emploie et
et et ça je pense que ça c'est un bon
esprit c'est un esprit combatif c'est un
esprit volontaire pas du
tout à échafauder et à
imaginer là aussi que dans notre esprit
nous nous nous nous nous ne
n'espérerions qu'une chose c'est de
fermer nos usines moi j'ai répondu moi
il y a qu'une chose à laquelle je
m'attache c'est de charger nos usines le
plus possible les faire tourner employer
le plus possible former développer les
compétences mais quand il n'y a plus de
clients ou quand notre compétitivité est
telle parce qu'aujourd'hui avec les
Coréens nous sommes à 2000 € d'écart en
compétitivité sur le segment B comment
faire pour le rattraper alors on va
rejoindre les autres questions la
question de la sous-traitance je
l'entends sur la compagnie
je peux vous dire que là sur ce sujet là
nous n'avons pas à rougir de ce que nous
avons fait depuis 2008 depuis 2008 alors
on peut refaire le passé soit on est
dans un monde qui est compétitif dans un
monde dans lequel nous l'agression est
forte c'est vrai que vis-à-vis de nos
fournisseurs on challenge nos
fournisseurs et certains de nos
fournisseurs sont des fournisseurs pas
des petits même des très gros mondiaux
qui dont les les profits je pe peux vous
dire sont d'une toute autre nature que
celui des constructeurs automobiles et
entre autre que du autre et bien nous
nous travaillons effectivement pour que
nos sous-traitants pour que la filière
automobile française elle existe pour
qu'elle pour qu'elle reste pour qu'elle
demeure mais qu'elle demeure compétitive
il on ne peut pas imaginer que toutes
les usines vivront là aussi dans tous
les pays du monde la reconcentration la
le le travail de restructuration a été
fait il a été fait en Allemagne il a été
fait aux États-Unis il n'a pas été fait
en France et nous nous y sommes employés
nous avons cherché là aussi à travailler
à optimiser la filière de l'emboutissage
je peux en parler nous avons aussi
cherché à travailler et optimiser la
filière de
l'étanchéité et d'autres filières et
nous continuons effectivement à œuvrer
pour avoir en France là aussi les
meilleurs dans ces activitésl est-ce
qu'ils pourront maintenir toutes leurs
activités je ne le sais pas nous ne
sommes pas seuls non plus hein et nous
ne pouvons pas être non plus le seul
d'neur d'ordre ce n'est pas possible
avec l'ensemble du tissu industriel mais
en tout cas pour les meilleurs d'entre
eux nous cherchons à ce qu'il le soit et
qu'il le demeure et là-dessus nous avons
pas ménagé notre peine et depuis 2008
nous consacrons là aussi des efforts
dans tous les domaines mais financiers
non
négligebles vous avez monsieur bourkine
ce titre évoquer un certain nombre de
sujets et d'une obligation de résultat
et d'avoir une obligation sur le retour
sur
emploi je vous entends et et et et et je
comprends et je sais que sur le sujet
effectivement on aurait peut-être pu le
travailler autrement le sujet des
amortisseurs c'est vrai là aussi je
pense que c'est notre responsabilité et
la responsabilité aussi avec les
territoires de faire venir les meilleurs
compétiteurs mon dans les meilleures
conditions qu'il soi peut-être
effectivement pour reprendre ce type
d'activité ça n'a pas été fait comme
cela je le
regrette maintenant dans l'avenir il
faut que je pense qu'on a entendu la
leçon néanmoins sur l'emploi je pense
qu'on a pas à rougir de ce que nous
avons fait l'année dernière nous avons
recruté plus de 3000 personnes nous
avons recruté 1800 ouvriers
bon on peut toujours faire mieux je
demanderai pas mieux mais je pense que
nous avons fait en ce qui nous concerne
les efforts qu'il faut sur l'emploi nous
faisons surtout une chose importante
c'est qu'en matière d'emploi nous
faisons aussi que vis-à-vis des hommes
et des femmes qui sont dans notre
entreprise nous faisons tout pour que
leur employabilité soit renforcée et que
leur emploi au sein de l'entreprise soit
assuré pour le long terme pour le plus
longtemps possible c'est ce que nous
nous efforçons de faire ce n'est pas
simple dans l'environnement qui est le
nôtre mais j'entends
votre la juste cause effectivement c'est
c'est c'est une préoccupation c'est
notre préoccupation c'est la
préoccupation de tout un chacun mais là
on le fait je vous le dis par rapport
aussi au marchés nos clients et notre
capacité à pouvoir effectivement
maintenir
l'emploi j'ai entendu aussi sur le sujet
de la Recherche et Développement là pas
de faux procès il faut arrêter il faut
arrêter non vous savez ce que vous
pouvez nous reprocher c'est d'avoir par
parler de nos
sous-traitants qui en
parle qui parle de ces prestataires dans
ces sociétés vous avez entendu les
grands groupes parler de leurs
prestataires dans les sociétés vous en
entendez jamais parler PSA le dit PSA
dit les choses mais pourquoi PSA a fait
ça parce que PSA il s'agit pas seulement
de nous dire mais faites donc comme les
Allemands et qu'est-ce que nous avons
fait dans les décisions qui ont été
prises par le président et la direction
générale à laquelle j'appartiens nous
avons décidé d'être aussi compétitif en
recherche et développement que les
Allemands il s'agit pas de chanter que
les Allemands font ceci que les
Allemands font cela mais faitesle donc
comme eux et bien on va essayer de faire
comme eux d'être aussi compétitif
c'est-à-dire que les millions qui sont
consacrés à la recherche et
développement nous essayons d'être aussi
compétitif que les Allemands et de
produire autant de véhicules et de
projets véhicules avec les effectifs et
les millions que nous injectons dans
notre recherche et développement alors
je rappelle parce que ça fait rigoler je
pense que les 400 personnes que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le China tech
Center à Shanghai qui vont devenir 1000
avec 1000 personnes vous ne faites pas
une voiture vous adaptez une voiture
c'est totalement différent vous adaptez
juste la peau c'est-à-dire vraiment les
pièces de carrosserie extérieure quoique
que quelques-unes et vous adaptez
quelques motorisations ce qui est le cas
au Brésil avec le flex fuel dont les
spécialistes sont les Brésiliens voilà
mais vous faites pas des voitures avec
400 voire bientôt 1000 personnes en
Chine faut pas rêver la base de nos
organ la base de nos savoir-faire
technologiques la base de nos projets
véhicules elle est en France elle est à
vis elle est à socho elle est à la Garen
et pour longtemps et pour longtemps
c'est c'est toutes nos compétences
moteur et boîte de vitesse qui est à la
Garen au jour d'aujourd'hui alors soyons
soyons sérieux elle n'est pas ailleurs
ailleurs on
fabrique des moteurs soit au Brésil soit
en Chine mais on ne on on sauf la la
spécificité du flex fuel que nous avons
au Brésil sorti de là tout est en région
parisienne donc arrêtons les faux procès
voilà donc sur soyez rassurés absolument
sur notre détermination d'avoir de
l'innovation et du développement fort en
France ce n'est pas ailleurs ailleurs
c'est de
l'adaptation merci Monsieur le Directeur
il nous reste 10 minutes simplement j'ai
encore quatre demandes de parole je
demanderai une 5è je demanderai à chacun
d'être très bref parce que ce serait par
politesse par rapport à l'audition
suivante donc il nous reste 10 minutes
monsieur Fouchet madame lettard monsieur
Teston monsieur Béco
et
pardon je retrouve tous les noms oui
mais t'inquiète pas tu tu auras la
parole donc 5 10 minutes donc une minute
chacun pour une minute minute de réponse
monsieur le directeur ça do faire le
compte allez on va pas faire les trois
vite monsieur président il de problème
bon allez go monsieur Foucher monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur le Directeur
simplement en une minute la question en
une minute ça sera dur de répondre pour
vous sans doute si je voulais savoir
vous en étiez dans le domaine de la
recherche et du développement sur les
véhicules à énergie nouvelle ce soit
électrique hybride par rapport vos
concurrents et en gros quel est votre
programme d'investissement dans ce
domaine merci voilà qui est concis euh
madame lard
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure et vous avez appelé mon
intervention concernant euh le site de
Sevel valenciennoise Sevel Nord ça ne
peut que me sensibiliser mais je vais
pas parler de la situation personnelle
mais
plutôt c'est que bien sûr vous êtes dans
un groupe français qui doit se situer
dans un contexte mondial et un GR groupe
français qui a choisi de produire pour
une bonne partie en France et qui a des
partenariats avec des opérateurs
d'autres opérateurs d'autres un enfin de
d'autres grands noms de la production
automobile qui sont donc italiens pour
l'occurrence sur le site du Nord et que
bah quelquefois c'est pas Peugeot qui
fait défaut c'est des partenariats avec
d'autres opérateurs qui mettent en
situation difficile Peugeot qui a décidé
de rester en France et là moi je peux en
témoigner sur mon territoire c'est que
face à des réalités qui s'annoncent à
l'horizon 2017 et bien on a un
constructeur français qui a pris la
tâche et qui c'est qui a tenu son
engagement en ce qui concerne un tour de
table une organisation avec les
territoires pour essayer d'anticiper les
choses et de se donner 3 ans pour
préparer une unité de production
nouvelle et trouver un nouveau
partenariat pour justement pas se
trouver en situation de difficulté si je
me permets de dire ça c'est parce que
moi je suis convaincu d'une chose pour
être sur un territoire très industriel
automobile et ferroviair autant vous
dire que des aléas on en connaît de
façon régulière on ne peut trouver des
solutions dans un monde comme vous
l'avez dit qui n'est pas un monde
uniforme dans un monde où on a des
marchés qui sont liés à la capacité de
consommation des ménages parce qu'on est
quand même sur un segment très sensible
et on est lié dans on est sur un segment
qui est en tout cas sur un secteur
d'activité qui est lié aussi une
évolution forte de la concurrence ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui de travailler entre
territoire
red partenaire universitaire la
recherche des territoires encore une
fois et des constructeur pour essayer de
trouver des solutions comme on le fait
aujourd'hui je voudrais
simplement par rapport à à cette réalité
que vous nous donniez là aussi quelques
précisions Monsieur Martin sur la façon
dont vous
envisagez les relations entre l'avenir
donc de votre de votre votre production
en France et la relation que nous avons
à mettre en œuvre aussi avec nos
sous-traitants car si nous voyons à peu
près clair aujourd'hui sur la stratégie
qui est la votre sur nos différents
territoires en France j'aimerais savoir
comment vous l'avez dit sur la
sous-traitance vous avez été peut-être
plus clair que les autres mais comment
vous voulez évoluer dans la relation
entre vous constructeurs et vos
partenaires sous-traitants pour faire en
sorte que nous ne connaissions plus les
difficultés actuelles merci Madame
Valérie lard la parole à Michel testan
très rapidement s'il vous plaît oui
merci monsieur monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur ma question
portera sur le Véhicule du Futur à
l'évidence PSA a fait le choix à court
et à moyen terme du véhicule hybride
est-ce que cela signifie que PSA ne
croit pas au véhicule tout électrique
très bien Monsieur Michel becco oui
monsieur le Président je vais pas faire
les questions et les réponses mais
j'accélère non Peugeot a toujours été un
très grand constructeur généraliste et
euh je voulais dire que je me je de mon
côté je me félicite que nous ayons
conserver et je dirais augmenter la
pourrecherche que vous utilisez
grandement bien entendu mais que vos
sous-traitants aussi utilise j'aurais
souhaité que vous répondiez finalement à
la question de d'Alain Châtillon tout à
l'heure vous avez certainement oublié
mais je vais y revenir parce que je
l'avais prévu également c'est la montée
en gamme de vos véhicules et je crois
que là il y a peut-être eu de de la part
de de vous-même un manque d'anticipation
pour les montter dans en gamme et
surtout le haut de gamme qu'on retrouve
en Europe bien entendu et vous savez
bien quel à qui je veux faire bien
sûr merci
Michel la parole est à Madame durriz et
à Madame Giselle prince mais deux fras
chacune
maximum pour laisser la parole à
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Directeur avec l'État la Région
nordpcalé et vous-même monsieur et
Monsieur monsieur Cohen directeur de la
Française de Mécanique une convention de
maintien des effectifs a été signé
jusque 2016 à pour l'instant 3100
ouvriers
minimum suite à cela des avec Clux des
aides financières importantes ont été
apporté et le moteur 3 cyindres va
sortir en mars 2013 ce qui est pour nous
très positif un nouveau moteur
aujourd'hui nous nous posons toujours la
question de la vitalité de l'entreprise
vu qu'un moteur Renault est en fin de
vie à la Française de Mécanique les
capitaux sont de 50 % PSA % Renault
alors que la fabrication est de 78 % C
PSA et 22 % Renault donc nous la
question que nous nous posons c'est
selon vous quelles orientations à
prendre et s'il faut en prendre pour une
améliorer une meilleure gouvernance de
l'entreprise merci a la parole à Giselle
prince pour deux phrases oui donc je
suis moselan alors j'aimerais bien
savoir quel est l'avenir de l'usine que
vous avez à Mosel voilà merci Monsieur
le Directeur vous avez le droit à 5
minutes vous par
contre bien écoutez euh monsieur le
Président sur les sur la red sur les
véhicules à énergie nouvelle bien
évidemment on y travaille mais euh bon
je crois qu'aussi il faut rester
réaliste hein là aussi les énergies
nouvelles ça a toujours fait rêver il y
a encore d'ailleurs ce matin je croyais
je croisais un de mes collègues mais
dans un tout autre monde et qui parlait
effectivement d'hydrogène mais c'est
quand il faisait ses études c'est-à-dire
il y a 35 ans et on lui disait était
l'énergie nouvelle donc c'est encore
aujourd'hui l'énergie nouvelle et je
pense que dans 30 35 ans on reparlera
effectivement d'énergie nouvelle en
attendant le moteur thermique il a
encore une longue vie devant devant lui
qu'il soit diesel ou qu'il soit essence
et nous travaillons fortement dessus et
d'ailleurs preuve en est l'arrivée du
moteur 3 cylindres au niveau du groupe à
la fois à tremerie mais également à
Française de Mécanique en est la preuve
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
sur les moteurs diesel sans sans sans
sans vraiment
flagornerie nous avons un des meilleurs
moteur diesel du monde qui est le dv6 et
je pense que il y a encore beaucoup
d'avenir devant lui sur le site de cvel
moi je j'apprécie madame n ce que ce que
vous dites la façon dont on envisage de
travailler moi je pense que ce type de
relation est essentiel c'està-dire
vraiment travailler avec les territoires
et ça c'est quelque chose qui me semble
important travailler effectivement avec
les élus et et et et les salariés mais
là aussi dans la réalité c'est c'est
très important et la réalité c'est une
réalité faite d'exigen faite de là aussi
de se mettre dans la transformation dans
la nos responsabilités pour pour ce s'y
préparer la relation avec les
sous-traitants je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure il faut que ce soit des
relations franches et sincères mais en
même temps de confiance et c'est ce que
nous avons commencé à bâtir depuis 2 ans
principalement avec nos fournisseurs qui
sont nos fournisseurs majeurs mais
également de plus en plus avec des
fournisseurs qui sont des des
fournisseurs d'entreprise de de de
moyenne taille et c'est ce que nous
essayons de de de lier de plus en plus
c'est des des des accords de longue
durée de long terme essentiellement
aussi basé pour leur donner cette
confiance et leur permettre de se
développer et de développer les
nouvelles technologies dont nous avons
besoin ensemble pour eux mais pour nous
également sur le Véhicule du Futur
est-ce qu'on ne croit pas au véhicules
tout électriques bon juste un mot
aujourd'hui nous faisons 30 % des ventes
des véhicules électriques en Europe
maintenant chacun en tire la philosophie
qu'il veut en tirer le véhicule
électrique a sûrement de de de beau
jours devant devant lui mais il reste
somme tout limité à des agglomérations
très urbaines et à certains usages et et
souvent avec un partage aussi et dans
certaines conditions voilà sur la montée
en gamme moi j'entends effectivement
est-ce qu'on l'a entendu tardivement bon
la question elle est elle est elle est
deux deux il y a deux questions il y a
principalement le haut de gamme le haut
de gamme les Allemands il y a un certain
nombre de raisons à cela euh je pense et
je je je je je je je préfère quand même
ce que nous avons fait en France sur nos
autoroutes à limiter la vitesse mais ça
aussi ça a favorisé les voitures à forte
cylindré est très haute puissance en
Allemagne en France ça ne sert à rien
d'avoir un 3 L ou au-delà de 3 l ça sert
strictement à rien et tout le monde le
sait euh on a aujourd'hui des très bons
de lites qui sont largement capables de
répondre en terme de puissance bon
néanmoins les Allemands il y a une
certaine image il y a aussi la taxation
et et la fiscalité qui ont pénalisé et
puis il y a aussi nous étions et nous
avons été et nous sommes aujourd'hui
avec C5 et 508 maintenant très présent
sur le segment D il faut quand même
rappeler que le segment D ce segment de
type de véhicule dans lequel nous sommes
pas mauvais euh c'est un segment qui a
s'est réduit de moitié en Europe en 10
an de moitié il était quasiment de
1500000 véhicules aujourd'hui il est à
peine de 700000 véhicules donc la
bataille est beaucoup plus difficile
voilà
donc ensuite écoutez sur FM je moi je me
sens très à l'aise alors c'est sûr que
il y a aussi un
partenaire vous lui poserai la question
mais en ce qui nous concerne nous nous
amenons de nouveaux moteurs nous avons
une activité
là aussi c'est une vie industrielle bon
et et votre collègue posait la question
sur trèmerie bon aujourd'hui tremerie
plutôt le vent poupe on est à 4000
personnes on lance le moteur
EB on va être plutôt en pleine charge FM
on a eu plus quelques difficultés mais
bon l'arrivée là aussi du moteur EB
turbo dans les prochains mois et d'ici
un an en production pleine série je
pense que en ce qui nous concerne nous
avons répondu à nos obligations à nos
engagements et nous nous y tiendrons
parce que là où nous sommes là où sont
nos usines nous sommes très attachés au
territoire sachez-les que ce soit à
tremer que ce soit à FM que ce soit à
sével que ce soit partout même à heny
nous sommes attachés au territoire nous
sommes surtout attachés à ce que nous
fassions de beaux produits et pour
lesquels les hommes et les femmes qui
sont au sein de PSA sont absolument
sachez-le fiers de le faire parce que
nos produits dans notre moté en gamme et
dans aussi nos efforts technologiques il
y a une fierté immense de produire ces
produits automobiles qui sont fabriqués
en France voilà merci Monsieur le
Directeur de vous être livré en tous les
cas je dirais un ensemble de flèches
locales mais ceci étant dit vous l'avez
situé dans la stratégie globale de votre
entreprise il est clair que vous n'êtes
pas isolé vous n'êtes pas une île au
milieu du d'un océan Pacifique et donc
je vous remercie en tous les cas de de
vos
réponses qui sont les vôtres et les
interrogations qui sont les nôtres et je
suis persuadé qu'il faudra bien que ça
converge un jour dans l'intérêt de
l'industrie d'une façon générale tout et
tout spécialement l'industrie automobile
merci encore de vous être livré à ce
petit exercice qui est tout à fait
toujours assez délicat voilà pour
l'audition de Denis Martin le directeur
général de PSA Peugeot Citroën à présent
je vous propose une autre audition celle
de Carlos tavarz c'est le directeur
général de Renault il a été également
entendu mardi par les sénateurs et vous
allez le voir lors de son audition il a
indiqué que fabriquer des voitures
Renault au Maroc générit de l'activité
en France on l'écoute très bien et bien
Madame la Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs membres de la commission
de l'économie du développement et de
l'aménagement du territoire membres du
groupe d'études industrie je suis très
honoré dans le cadre de ce débat
euh de vous présenter aujourd'hui
quelques éléments de la stratégie du
groupe Renault et en particulier vous
expliquer la situation de
l'entreprise qui a un grand potentiel
qui reste fragile mais pour laquelle je
pense qu'il est légitime d'avoir des
grandes ambitions celles du champion
français de l'automobile alors dans les
messages que je voulais vous adresser je
voulais les classer en trois grandes
catégories d'abord vous vous parlez de
la situation de Renault comme je viens
de vous dire à l'instant décrire un peu
sa fragilité mais aussi son potentiel
vous parlez ensuite probablement du du
thème qui vous intéresse le plus à
savoir la France comme base de
croissance de
l'entreprise et et enfin conclure sur la
vision que nous avons pour pour ce
groupe et comment nous le voyons évoluer
dans les années à
venir alors sur sur un des slides que
j'aurais pu et voulu vous montrer euh je
voulais d'abord vous dire que que
Renault est un constructeur automobile
de petite taille à l'échelle mondiale
nous avons 3 % du marché mondial donc ça
reste ça reste petit même si comme vous
le savez nous sommes leader du marché
français nous sommes la deuxème marque
du marché européen juste derrière
Volkswagen et nous avons battu en 2011
notre record mondial de vente avec 2,7
millions de voiture donc nous
représentons 3 % du marché mondial nous
sommes la 16e euh capitalisation
boursière du monde automobile notamment
grâce à nos
participations chez Nissan mais
également chez demler et chez Renault
Samsung
Motors c'est une une entreprise qui a du
mal à être rentable de manière de
manière récurrente et sur le SAL que
j'ai ici sur les yeux je vous aurais
montré le fait que sur les 10 dernières
années Renault n'a pas réussi à dégager
un un fris cachelot positif de manière
récurrente autrement dit Rena n'a pas
réussi à générer de l'autofinancement de
manière récurrente il y a eu des
périodes où sur 3 années de 2003 à 2005
nous avons réussi à être positif nous
avons ensuite en 2008-2009
aussi connu des périodes de fricachelot
négatif ce qui est évidemment difficile
et en en 2010 nous avons été positifs
donc voilà pour vous dire d'abord que
c'est une entreprise qui a du mal de
manière récurrente à dégager un fricage
positif c'est une entreprise qui a une
marge opérationnelle relativement faible
vous savez qu'au premier semestre 2011
nous avons annoncé 3 % de marge
opérationnel dont deux fait par le
financement des ventes et un par
l'activité automobile si vous lisez un
peu la presse financière vous verrez que
les experts de l'industrie automobile
considèrent que nous ne créons pas de
valeur au niveau de notre corp business
il considèent que euh l'activité de
Renault en tant que constructeur
automobile n'est pas une activité qui
génère de manière récurrente et sur la
longue période euh un fricachelot
positif ceci est évidemment quelque
chose qui ne nous satisfait pas nous
considérons que nous devons régler ce
problème-là et pour cela améliorer à la
fois l'amplitude de de notre rentabilité
et la récurrence de cette
rentabilité bien monsieur euh il va
falloir que je vous quitte pendant
quelques minutes parce que je dois aller
faire un rapport sur l'application des
lois dans l'hémicycle je laisse la
parole à à quelqu'un qui s'intéresse de
loin à l'automobile enfin en région de
son origine je je vais parler du rapport
qu'il a commis sur la
désindustrialisation autrement dit
Monsieur Martial Bourquin voilà donc à
tout à l'heure mes chers
collègues
Mons tavz merci donc je je poursuis euh
donc en en vous en vous disant que une
des difficulté majeure de Renault c'est
d'avoir aujourd'hui un point mort de
marge opérationnelle qui est
relativement élevé je vais juste vous
donner deux chiffres pour illustrer ce
propos euh nous avons en 2011 comme je
l'ai dit battu notre record mondial de
vente avec 2,7 millions de voitures et
notre point mort de marge opérationnelle
en 2011 était à hauteur de 2,67 millions
donc nous avons un point mort qui est
très élevé qui est le résultat de deux
facteurs d'une part la croissance des
frais fixes de l'entreprise au cours des
dernières années et d'autre part une
certaine érosion de la marge unitaire de
nos ventes qui est la conséquence de la
guerre qui est livrée par les différents
constructeurs notamment sur le marché
européen dont nous sommes encore très
dépendants puisque vous savez qu'en 2011
nous avons fait 47 % euh plutôt 57 %
pardon 57 % de nos ventes en Europe
occidentale donc une entreprise qui a du
mal à avoir un fréachelot positif de
manière récurrente une marge
opérationnelle qui reste faible avec un
un point mort de marge opérationnelle
très élevé et trop proche des ventes
courantes de l'entreprise malgré ceci
comme vous le savez nous n'avons pas
annoncé de profit warning pour 2011 et
nous n'avons pas annoncé de mesures
difficile sur le plan de l'emploi
puisque nous n'avons pas annoncé de plan
social notamment en France voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire pour commencer je
voulais également vous vous préciser que
au-delà de cette fragilité l'entreprise
est bourrée de talent j'ai été comme
vous le savez absent chez Nissan pendant
7 ans 5 ans au Japon et 2 ans aux
États-Unis et à mon retour de ces 7
années d'expatriation il y a deux choses
qui m'ont frappé la première chose c'est
le fait que Renault
a réussi au cours des dernières années
une amélioration tout à fait
spectaculaire de son niveau de qualité
et la deuxième chose c'est que nous
avons dans l'entreprise à la fois du
talent créatif et un niveau d'engagement
dans le succès de l'entreprise que je
considère de très haut niveau donc je ne
suis pas du tout pessimiste quant à
l'avenir de l'entreprise mais je me dois
de vous signaler la fragilité car il est
souvent euh il est courant de d'entendre
parler de Ren comme si c'était une
entreprise indestructible elle ne l'est
pas elle est très fragile au niveau de
sa rentabilité alors pourquoi est-ce que
Renault est et et continuera d'être le
champion français de l'industrie
automobile nous avons d'abord un niveau
d'engagement comme je vous l'ai dit de
la part de nos de nos salariés qui est
très élevé nous avons réussi une
amélioration de qualité de la qualité
qui a été tout à fait spectaculaire je
cite à ce propos les enquêtes qui sont
faites par le constructeur automobile
allemand ADAC auprès des consommateurs
allemands où de manière statistique ce
cet Automobile Club compare le nombre de
pannes de tous les véhicules qui
circulent sur le le réseau routier
allemand et pour vous dire que jugé par
des consommateurs allemands et rapporté
par l'Automobile club allemand àc les
produits Renault sont souvent dans de
nombreux segments devant leurs
homologues allemands eux aussi et donc
je pense qu'il y a la matière sans
arrogance mais avec confiance d'affirmer
mais que les véhicules redeo ont
maintenant atteint le meilleur niveau
qualité sans pour autant considérer que
la partie est gagnée puisque comme vous
savez la qualité est un combat de tous
les jours un autre domaine dans lequel
je crois qu'il faut reconnaître
l'excellence de la performance du groupe
Reno c'est celui des moteur alors
évidemment vous savez tous que nous
avons remporté en 2011 notre 10e titre
de motoriste en championnat du monde de
Formule 1 que ça fait 30 ans que
l'entreprise est engagée dans cette
compétition au plus haut au niveau et
qu'il est bien rare qu'un constructeur
automobile a remporté 10 titres mondiaux
en l'espace de 30 années de
participation ceci se traduit dans
l'excellence de nos produits en terme de
motorisation je vais vous donner
simplement deux exemples d'abord vous
dire que nous avons un roadmap de
réduction des émissions de CO2 qui nous
amemène en 2020 à 80 g par kilomè
parcouru et que nous allons euh délivrer
nos engagements en 2016 c'est-à-dire
dans l'année de sortie du plan moyen
terme actuel nous aurons une gamme qui
en moyenne pondérée des ventes sera en
dessous de 100 g d'émission de CO2 et
ceci pas uniquement grâce à nos
véhicules électriques mais aussi grâce à
l'excellence des motorisations que nous
faisons évoluer chaque chaque année
comme les motorisations diesel où nous
avons la prétention d'avoir des moteurs
diesel au meilleur niveau de performance
y compris par rapport à nos concurrents
allemands j'en veux pour preuve une
voiture qui le mois dernier a fait un
tabac au Pays-Bas qui comme vous savez
le pays européen où les où la
réglementation et la fiscalité sur les
émissions de CO2 sont les plus sévères
et bien nous avons une Mégane avec un
moteur diesel qui fait 90 g de CO2 au
kilomèt parcouru et nous allons avoir
cette année une twingo à 85 g j'affirme
donc que Renault au travers de
l'excellence de ces motorisations est à
la pointe de l'équilibre perfo conso sur
les motorisations diesel et j'en profite
pour rappeler ici que en 2012 nous
allons lancer une nouvelle génération de
moteur essence injection
directe cylindré rédu turbo qui vont
aussi nous positionner au meilleur
niveau y compris par rapport à nos
concurrents allemands et je veux donc
simplement vous vous dire que au niveau
des
motorisations une fois de plus sans
arrogance mais avec confiance je veux
affirmer ici que Renault est un champion
des motorisations un plan produit
robuste tout simplement parce que nous
allons connaître à partir de cette année
une accé une accélération du
renouvellement de notre gamme nous avons
connu ces dernières années une période
un peu difficile qui a conduit au
viéissement de notre de notre de notre
gamme ceci est maintenant derrière nous
et nous allons nous avons attaqué 2012
avec la phase 2 de la Twingo qui comme
vous savez a été très bien reçu par la
presse avec un design rafraîchi et rendu
plus plus sympathique nous avons au
printemps le lancement de la Renault Ty
qui va je pense
apporter une dimension nouvelle à la
mobilité urbaine zéro émission nous
aurons la Renault ZOE donc à l'automne
ainsi que la 4e génération de Clio qui
dans l'avant-dernière année de sa vie a
été le véhicule le plus vendu sur le
marché français faut-il le rappeler nous
allons aussi avoir comme vous le savez
le lancement de notre premier monospace
avec badge dasia le logi ainsi qu'une
fourgonnette également badget Badet d'IA
donc beaucoup de nouveautés cette année
et je voulais simplement vous dire que
sur la période
2012-24 c'est-à-dire sur 3 années nous
allons lancer 23 nouveaux modèles donc
Renault rentre dans une période de fort
renouvellement de sa gamme avec une une
stratégie qui bénéficie à la rentabilité
du groupe qui est de continuer de
croître à l'international pendant que
nous protégeons nos positions sur le
marché européen je veux simplement
rappeler de chiffres en
1999 11 % de la production ou 11 %
pardon des ventes de Renault était faite
en dehors de l'Europe occidentale en
1999 en 2011 le 11 % de 99 est devenu 43
% et et je précise que cette croissance
qui est tirée par de nombreux marchés
émergents mais notamment la Russie et et
le Brésil sont deux marchés sur lesquels
notre rentabilité est bonne ce qui veut
dire que lorsque notre mix de vente
s'améliore à l'international c'est le
mix de rentabilité de l'entreprise qui
s'améliore et c'est donc la rentabilité
de l'entreprise toute entière qui
s'améliore voilà sur le point suivant je
voulais vous donner un aperçu de comment
nous voyons la croissance des marchés
automobiles pour les prochaines années
et nous avons simplement fait un
distingo entre l'Europe et le reste du
monde alors vous voyez ici d'abord que
sur l'Europe en prenant comme point de
référence basse 100 l'année 2007 nous
pensons que nous serons de retour au
niveau que nous avons connu en 2007
probablement à l'issu du plan moyen
terme actuel qui se termine en 2016 où
nous devrions être proches de retrouver
le niveau de 2007 donc vous voyez une
phase relativement longue de
récupération de la crise qui qui nous
frappe hors d'Europe vous voyez que dès
l'année 2010 les volumes continuaient de
croître et donc nous voyons 48 %
d'augmentation en 2016 comparé à l'année
de référence 2007 donc en fait une photo
très contrastée d'une Europe qui essaie
de se récupérer et de de retrouver son
niveau d'avant-crise alors que à
l'extérieur de l'Europe les marchés
continuent continuent de croîre alors
ceci est d'autant plus important que il
faut garder présent à l'esprit quelques
chiffres qui sont un peu douloureux mais
je pense qu'il faut regarder la réalité
la réalité en face d'abord vous dire que
le niveau de motorisation en Europe est
de 700 véhicules pour 1000 habitants
alors que le niveau de motorisation
comme nous le savons tous dans les pays
argent en Inde il est de 15 voitures
pour 1000 habitants au Brésil de 150
voitures pour 1000 habitants ce qui
explique pourquoi le besoin de mobilité
et de liberté de ces peuples les conduit
à croître la taille de leur marché par
par l'expression de de ces besoins c'est
un premier point deuxième point qui est
important que nous avons recalculé très
récemment c'est que nous avons en Europe
une situation tout à fait particulière
d'une forte surcapacité de fabrication
de véhicules automobiles ceci vient
vient du fait que l'Europe a eu une
stratégie pendant la crise complètement
opposée à celle d'autres d'autres
régions du monde en particulier opposé à
celle des États-Unis où vous savez que
pendant la crise aux États-Unis de
nombreuses usines automobiles ont été
fermées à hauteur de 4 à 5 millions de
véhicules produit par an ont été rayés
de la capacité de production donc les
États-Unis pendant les années 2009- 2010
ont réduit leur capacité de fabrication
automobile de l'ordre de 4 à 5 millions
de véhicules pendant la même période
nous en Europe nous avons choisi de ne
pas le faire ou de le faire de façon
tout à fait marginale la conséquence en
est que alors où je vous parle la
surcapacité industrielle automobile en
Europe elle est soit de 3 millions si
vous comp si vous prenez en référence un
fonctionnement des usines en deux
équipes soit de 11 millions de véhicules
par an si vous prenez en référence un
fonctionnement des usines à trois
équipes journalières et inutile de
préciser que pour que une une usine en
Europe Europe soit performante sur le
plan de sa de sa fabrication il est
préférable qu'elle soit en trois équipes
donc voyez de 3 à 11 millions de
véhicules c'est la surcapacité de
l'industrie automobile européenne par
rapport au niveau courant du marché et
donc vous voyez là la raison principale
pour laquelle nous avons une guerre des
prix extrêmement sévère guerre des prix
qui conduit de
nombreux constructeur automobile à à
baissé leur prix au travers de discant
qui sont destructeurs de la valeur de
leur marque et qui mettent leurs
entreprises dans le rouge parce qu'ils
vendent leur voiture à un niveau qui
n'est pas rémunérateur et c'est ce que
vous observez en ce moment puisque si
vous lisez la presse et bien vous verrez
que PSA est dans le rouge vous verrez
que Fiat est dans le rouge vous verrez
que fort d'Europe est dans le rouge vous
verrez que Opel est dans le rouge donc
tous les constructeurs européens sont
dans le rouge fort heureusement la
situation de Renault n'est pas celle-là
mais je veux vous alerter sur le fait
que la surcapacité industrielle
automobile en Europe n'a pas été traité
et que ceci pèse sur sur la rentabilité
des des groupes automobiles alors un
point un point qui est assez assez
paradoxal et c'est une question qu'on
m'adresse souvent c'est dire ah oui mais
vous comprenez dashia est fait à
l'extérieerur de la France est en train
de cannibaliser Renault et bien sachez
ceci sachez que les véhicules d'ashia
ont été fabriqués pour être ont été
conçus pour être fabriqué à un coup très
bas ils sont par ailleurs fabriqués dans
des dans des usines également à bacoup
ce qui nous permet sur les marchés
matures marchés d'Europe occidentale de
mettre en face des mouvements désespérés
de nos concurrents qui eux n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de discanter leur
voiture et bien nous mettons en face de
ces de ces manœuvres désespérées des
véhicules à bas prix avec lesquels nous
faisons du profit ce qui permet donc de
maintenir l'entreprise à flot et de
manière
assez paradoxale dans l'esprit de
certains c'est bien les véhicules à BAP
prix qui ont été conçus et qui sont
fabriqués à des niveaux d'efficacité
importants qui nous permettent de
générer les profits qui permettent de
garder
l'entreprise dans une bonne santé
relative par rapport à nos concurrents
qui d'une façon ou d'une autre sont tous
en train d'engager l'équivalent de ce
que nous appellerions des plans sociaux
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire pour
pour la situation de Renault et pour la
situation de l'industrie automobile en
Europe telle que nous la voyons euh avec
je vous le rappelle un point important
c'est le fait que nous allons continuer
à développer nos ventes internationales
pour le meilleur bénéfice de
l'entreprise et de notre activité en
France alors parlons-en de la France et
de notre rôle dans dans notre pays
d'abord pour vous rappeler que Renault
emploie 54000 personnes en direct en
France que nos fournisseurs emploient
70000 personnes et qu'au travers de
notre réseau commercial ce sont 47000
personnes supplémentaires qui sont qui
sont engagées donc au amo 170000
personnes sont dépendantes directement
de l'activité de notre groupe c'estd
l'importance de notre responsabilité je
voulais également vous dire que au
travers de l'évaluation que nous faisons
très régulièrement nous avons investi en
l'espace de 8 ans 6 milliards d'euros en
en France et que ceci représente 40 % de
nos investissements totaux ce qui en
regard de pourcentage de vente que nous
faisons en France qui est de l'ordre de
5 % est un chiffre significatif qui qui
mérite d'être souligné je vais également
préciser que au début du plan moyen
terme qui est actuellement le nôtre qui
va de de 2011 à 2016 le plan 2016 drive
the change nous avons pour chacun des
sites industriel français un avenir qui
est qui est clair je ne dirais pas qu'il
est optimal mais il est clair au sens de
l'affectation des produits euh qui ont
été qui ont été décidés et je veux
simplement vous rappeler que notre notre
stratégie c'est de concentrer en France
tous les produits à forte valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire les véhicules de haute
gamme les véhicules électriques les
véhicules utilitaires pour lesquels je
vous rappelle que sur les 14 dernières
années Renault a été le leader sur le
marché européen des véhicules
utilitaires alors on disait que nous
avons pour chaque site industriel un
avenir je voudrais rappeler les éléments
essentiels de ceci d'abord vous rappelez
que contrairement à ce que disent
certains qui se plaisent à rappeler que
Renault délocalise je voulais rappeler
que nous avons relocalisé à Sandouville
le Renault traffic qui actuellement est
fabriqué à Barcelone chez Nissan et à
leuton chez GM que nous l'avons
relocalisé à Sandouville avec un montant
d'investissement de 230 millions d'euros
et que nous sommes actuellement en train
de modifier l'usine dans ce sens je
voulais rappeler que pour Flin nous
avons prévu cette année le lancement de
la Clo 4e génération et de la Renault
ZOE véhicule 100 % électrique à très
forte valeur ajoutée euh et que nous
allons au printemps poser la première
pierre de l'usine de batterie que nous
allons implanter sur ce site je voulais
rappeler que nous avons à maobug non
seulement la production du Kangou mais
que grâce à la performance de nos
collaborateurs sur le plan de la qualité
et sur le plan des coups nous avons pu
convaincre notre partenaire demler de
faire fabriquer à maobeuge un dérivé
pour demler avec badge Mercedes de notre
petit utilitaire et que ceci est la
meilleure preuve euh de la compétitivité
que l'on peut assurer en France lorsque
nous avons d'un côté un partenaire qui a
du pricing Power et de l'autre côté un
fournisseur qui a une compétence en
matière de gestion des coûts et et de la
qualité je veux également rappeler que
nous avons lancé à batily en 2010 un
produit ou plutôt une famille de
produits extrêmement riches qui
s'appelle la famille master qui est
amené à vivre pendant de nombreuses
années comporte de nombreuses versions
traction propulsion moteur diesel de
différentes cylindres
et de nombreuses applications
d'empattement et de hauteur rappelez
aussi ce que j'ai l'autre jour annoncé à
la commission économique le fait que à
Doué nous allons industrialiser les
véhicules du segment C et du segment D
c'estàdire la gamme moyenne et la gamme
haute pour un montant d'investissement
total de 420 millions d'euros sur ce
site pour y voir fabriquer les
remplaçants de l'espace de Laguna de
Scénic et de grand Sénic et il s'agit
donc d'un investissement cons ble qui
d'ailleurs représente pour les salariés
du site un challenge important puisque
de nombreux véhicules sont à lancés dans
un espace-temp relativement court je
voulais également vous dire que nous
avons en liaison avec ce que je vous
disais sur l'excellence de nos
motorisation une activité dans l'usine
de Cléon qui est notre usine de
mécanique en France avec avec leement
une activité extrêmement soutenue
pourquoi est-elle soutenue parce que
l'excellence de nos motorisations et
notamment nos motorisations diesel et
est reconnu par nos partenaires reconnu
par Nissan reconnu par par demler et
donc leur propre croissance vient
s'additionner à la nôtre pour tirer
l'activité sur sur ce site qui
d'ailleurs travaille à pleine cadence et
cette cette activité qui qui est
croissante par la reconnaissance de la
performance qualité et de la performance
tout cours de ces motorisations va
générer sur le moyen terme un
investissement de de 300 millions
d'euros sur ce site de de Cléon qui
intègre aussi l'investissement que nous
avons décidé de faire pour y fabriquer
le moteur électrique de demain pour nos
véhicules électriques c'estàdire la
prochaine génération de moteurs
électriques qui seront bien
plus économe que la génération actuelle
donc c'est déjà l'étape d'après en
matière d'efficacité design to cost des
éléments de la chaîne de traction
électrique donc vous voyez que quand on
dit que on investit en France les
activités à forte valeur ajoutée et bien
on traduit cela dans les décisions que
nous prenons euh voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire euh pour l'essentiel vous
rappelez enfin que nous avons en France
euh des activités non seulement de
moteur mais aussi des activités châssis
des activités de transmission et que si
vous regardez de près on est tout à fait
en mesure de vous communiquer ces
chiffres vous verrez qu'on produit en
France un nombre de moteurs de
transmission et d'éléments de châssis
euh dans notre usine notamment de
d'ument euh châssis train avant train
arrière bien supérieur au nombre de
véhicules que nous vendons euh en France
ce qui signifie tout simplement que nous
exportons à partir de notre base
industrielle française euh voilà je
voulais maintenant vous vous dire deux
mots sur eu le véhicule électrique
d'abord parce que c'est mon plaisir et
parce que je sais que ça va être un
élément contrastant par rapport à
l'intervention qui probablement a été
faite par mon respecté collègue de de
PSA pour vous dire que que contrairement
à ce qu'on m'a dit quand je suis arrivé
en France en juillet 2011 le véhicule
électrique n'est pas un Paris le
véhicule électrique est à la fois un un
choix de leadership stratégique et une
assurance alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est un c'est un une assurance tout
simplement parce que nous savons
parfaitement que la probabilité pour que
le prix du pétrole à Man ou à un autre
augmente de manière rapide est très
forte cette probabilité elle est soit la
conséquence du tirage de la croissance
mondiale et notamment la croissance des
pays émergents qui va tirer sur
finalement euh les réserves existantes
sur les capacités existantes mais il y a
aussi un autre facteur qui est plus un
facteur géopolitique c'est que la
moindre tension euh en matière
d'approvisionnement crée immédiatement
des anxiétés qui se traduissent par une
envolée des prix du pétrole donc
contrairement à ce que certains pensent
je considère que le ville électrique
c'est non seulement l'opportunité pour
Renault de prendre le leadership sur les
véhicules zéro émission je voudrais
rappeler qu'une fois qu'on a atteint
zéro on peut pas être doublé parce qu'on
peut pas faire mieux que zéro émission
donc la question c'est de savoir si on
est à zéro et la question c'est de
savoir si on est efficace dans notre
capacité à produire des véhicules zéro
émission et ça c'est le coût d'avance
que nous sommes en train de prendre
puisque plutôt nous en fabriquerons
plutôt nous passerons à la forte cadence
et plutôt nous apprendrons à réduire
leur coût et à être accessible plus
grand nombre donc Renault a pris une
position courageuse de leadership dans
ce domaine et ça se traduit par
l'existence de quatre véhicules sur
quatre segments très différents comme le
Renault kangu la la Renault Fluence le
Renault tuisi et le Renault Zoé ce sera
comme je l'ai dit également une
assurance qui fera que dès l'instant que
une perturbation pourra se produire ou
pourrait se produire sur
l'approvisionnement de pétrole nous
verrons le prix de s augmenté de manière
extrêmement forte avec tout ce que ça
comporte comme élément de
déstabilisation sociale des pays qui
dépendre fortement du pétrole et bien
nous aurons une solution qui sera une
solution économique ce ne sera pas à ce
moment-là un choix qui sera fait par
ceux qui sont particulièrement sensibles
à l'avenir de notre planète mais ce sera
surtout un choix pragmatique de coup de
revien kilométrique qui sera beaucoup
plus intéressant qu'un véhicule
traditionnel je voulais je voulais
rappeler que nous avons également euh le
souci en tant que parents ou
grands-parents euh de voir nos enfants
ou nos petits-enfants protéger leur
planète et nous sommes nous sommes en
train d'éduquer une génération qui par
conséquence de l'éducation qu'ils sont
en train de recevoir feront un choix de
leur outil de mobilité parmi les
véhicules qui seront zéro émission car à
prix identique quelle bonne raison
aurait-il de ne pas choisir un véhicule
qui euh protège la planète euh qui comme
nous le savons est la seule dont nous
disposons
voilà je voulais je voulais également
finir ce point simplement en signalant
qu'il est très important que la France
puisse maintenir son leadership dans ce
domaine et ce leadership ne pourra
s'établir que si nous créons les
conditions pour une utilisation
confortable et aisé des véhicules
électriques je me
réjouis du fait que la France est s
rédiger le Livre vert il est important
maintenant que les conclusions du Livre
vert soient mises à exécution ce qui
n'est pas je crois le cas aujourd'hui je
vous donnerai quelques exemples je
voulais aussi euh vous rappeler que nous
avons eu le le bonheur de voir notre
compétence reconnue par le fait que
l'UGAP nous a choisi pour fournir 15500
Renault kangu électrique dans le cadre
de son appel d'offre tel qu'il a été
officialisé à la fin de l'année dernière
alors pour en revenir au Livre vert euh
je pense que nous avons perdu beaucoup
de temps nous avons perdu d'abord 6 mois
dans la publication du livre livre vert
en soi nous avons ensuite perdu 6 mois
dans des discussions plutôt stériles sur
la question de savoir si on pouvait ou
pas mettre un véhicule électrique dans
un parking souterrain je voulais aussi
dire que nous attendons toujours une
accélération accélération de la mise en
place des points de chargement à à fin
2011 nous en avions environ entre 500 et
1000 de type mode 3 au lieu des 2000 qui
étaient prévu et nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
prendre du retard sur la mise en place
de ces de ces points de chargement qui
sont indispensables à au confort
d'utilisation de nos clients et donc je
constate aussi que aucun dossier n'a été
présenté au grand emprunt pour accélérer
la mise en place de ce réseau de
chargement des véhicule électrique je
trouve que c'est une question qui
dépasse l'intérêt de Renault parce que
l'intérêt de Renault se conjugue sur ce
thème avec l'intérêt de la France si euh
nous ne développons pas euh une une une
économie euh à partir de mobilité
durable je peux vous dire qu'il y a
d'autres pays dans le monde à commencé
par la Chine qui lu feront à are place
et j'uris de la peine à constater que la
France perd cette opportunité alors que
ses constructeurs automobiles au moins
son constructeur automobile est capable
de fournir des produits au bon niveau
technologique voilà pour le véhicule
électrique je poursuis sur la
croissance simplement pour vous dire
quelque chose d'assez simple d'abord
pour vous dire que chaque fois que on
vend un véhicule de la gamme entry pour
faire simple un véhicule d'achia on
génère 800 € d'activité en France pour
vous dire que en étant cohérent avec
notre stratégie de développement des
produits à forte valeur rjouté et les
nouvelles technologies en France nous
aurons 80 % de nos dépenses d'ingénierie
qui seront localisé en France et enfin
vous dire également en toute
transparence et c'est un chiffre qui
peut-être vous choquera que lorsqu'on
compare le prix de revient rendu chez le
concessionnaire de la future Clio 4 que
nous allons fabriquer à la fois en
Turquie et en France comme vous le savez
donc nous avons une grande capacité à
comparer avec grande rigueur le prix de
revient livré de la voiture puisque nous
avons les deux sourcing et bien quand on
compare le prix d'une Clio 4 fabriqué en
France à Flin avec celui de la même
voiture fabriquée en Turquie et bien il
y a 1300 € d'écart en défaveur de la
France telle est la valeur
d'amplitude d'écart de compétitivité que
nous constatons aujourd'hui je ne dis
pas que on ne puisse pas le réduire je
ne puisse pas je ne dis pas qu'on ne
puisse pas y travailler mais je
souhaiterais que vous gardiez l'ordre de
grandeur en tête parce que vous pourrez
ensuite le le comparer à l'ordre de
grandeur des marges que les
constructeurs automobiles en Europe font
sur ce type de voiture et vous verrez
que c'est pas du tout négligeable c'est
du mémire de grandeur je voulais
également vous dire que chaque fois que
l'on fabrique un véhicule à tangé
puisque c'est l'objet de discussion
actuelle et bien la fabrication d'une
voiture à Tanger rapportera 800 € à la
France parce qu'il y a 400 € de pièces
livrées à partir de la France et 400 €
d'ingénierie également donc une fois de
plus l'activité qui est créée à
l'international qui génère du profit et
qui permet à l'entreprise de se
développer tire l'activité en France
enfin juste un ordre de grandeur pour
vous dire que études que nous avons
faites que les Américains appellent le
cross shopping c'est-à-dire quels sont
les produits d'hésitation les marques
d'hésitation lorsqu'un client euh
cherche à acheter une Renault seul 5 %
des clients achetant une Renault ont
hésité entre une Renault et une dashia
autant dire que dasia ne cannibalise pas
Renault dashia se nourrit euh du marché
des véhicules d'occasion et en fait on
permet à des gens qui normalement
achèteraient un véhicule d'occasion
d'acheter un véhicule neuf et d'ailleurs
on assiste c'est assez sympathique à euh
euh une une liaison vraiment très
affective entre les clients de dasia et
et leur voiture à tel point que on
pourrait penser qu'une dashia est une
voiture plutôt courante et bien sachez
qu'il y a beaucoup de clubs de
possesseurs de Dacia qui sont
extrêmement dynamiques avec des gens qui
sont très fiers euh de posséder une
telle voiture tout simplement parce que
c'est leur première voiture neuve voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire sur ce thème
euh ensuite vous parler euh rapidement
du du tssu fournisseur vous savez que
nous sommes engâés avec nos collègues de
PSA et et les grands et les grands
fournisseurs dans la mise en place d'une
filière automobile qui sera très
probablement annoncé très bientôt je
pense que les fondations de cette
filière sont la mise en place au niveau
de son organisation de ces de ces
comités de
gouvernance et que ceci va va pouvoir
avancer néanmoins je je me permet de
partager avec vous le fait que là encore
je pense que nous avons pris du retard
euh vous voyez deux chiffres simple au
cours des dernières années la production
a baissé de 37 % les effectifs de 19
c'est un un élément parmi d'autres qui
démontre qu'il y a une déformation qui
ne s'est pas produite je voulais
également vous dire que nous avons en
tant que groupe Renault déjà beaucoup
beaucoup payé et et beaucoup participé
au soutien de notre de notre base
fournisseur d'abord en acceptant des
conditions de des changements de
conditions de paiement pour que le free
cash flow de nos fourniss s'améliore
ensuite en mettant 200 millions d'euros
dans le FMEA pour venir en aide à des
fournisseurs qui nécessiteraient
restructuration et enfin vous dire que
en cashout net c'est-à-dire en aide
directe sans aucune forme de contreparti
nous avons dépensé en 2011 74 millions
d'euros cash out direct pour soutenir
des fournisseurs et vous conviendrez
avec moi que l'amplitude de ces sommes à
un moment donné est questionné par nos
propres employés nos propres
collaborateurs qui nous demandent
pourquoi nous dépensons autant d'argent
pour venir en aide à des entreprises qui
ont leur
propre direction leur propre comité
stratégique et leur propre
responsabilité dans la pérenité de ces
entreprises donc soutien à notre panel
fournisseur vous pouvez terminer parce
qu'on a encore à peine un quart d'heure
pour les questions des sénateur très
bien je vais finir en 2 minutes donc je
voudrais que ceci soit reconnu par
l'ensemble des des par partie prenante
dernière dernier slide et je je vais en
finir là simplement pour vous dire
que si on regarde quel est notre notre
vision de de l'entreprise Renault
d'abord une entreprise qui restera à la
pointe de l'innovation alors innovation
conceptuelle la Renault tuisi en est un
exemple une entreprise qui innove sur le
plan technologique le véhicule
électrique en est un exemple vivant les
motorisations en sont un autre j'aurais
pu citer aussi la connectivité que nous
avons présenté euh à la conférence Web
eleven l'année dernière pour vous dire
que cette année on sera probablement le
premier constructeur qui va intégrer sur
la planche de bord d'un de ces véhicules
compact une tablette euh et ça c'est
important euh donc exemple de
d'innovation euh on on gardera euh cette
cette vision stratégique euh de ce que
Renault doit doit rester un leader
mondial euh sur le plan des véhicules
électriques comme je vous ai dit zéro
émission c'est difficile de faire mieux
que zéro nous continuerons à dével nos
activités à l'international pour une
raison assez simple c'est que ceci
permet à l'entreprise d'assurer la
récurrence de ces profit de sa
rentabilité et de ce fait d'assurer sa
pérenité sachant que beaucoup des
marchés émergents sont des marchés
rentables nous continuerons à avoir un
schéma industriel qui sera de fabriquer
nos véhicules à proximité des marchés
dans lequels nous les vendons pour une
raison assez simple c'est que nous avons
deux facteurs qui sont exogènes le
premier ce sont les barrières douanières
et elles sont encore très importantes et
et très fortes je veux simplement vous
rappeler deux chiffres pour importer un
véhicule complet au Brésil la taxe
d'importation est de 35 % euh pour
importer un véhicule complet euh en
Russie c'est 35 % et en Inde c'est 100
%. donc c'est une réalité alors on peut
nous parler euh de l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce mais la réalité
c'est qu'il y a encore énormément de
taxes et la réalité c'est que il y a un
autre facteur qui est la sensibilité au
taux de change qui est également un
facteur exogène et et pratiquement
incontrôlable euh donc nous continuerons
à fabriquer des voitures à proximité des
marchés dans lesquels nous les vendons
Renault continuera d'être une entreprise
humaniste où la passion de ses
collaborateurs et le moteur numéro 1 et
finalement je voudrais simplement vous
dire que notre mission en tant que
dirigeant d'entreprise c'est d'assurer
la pérénité de l'entreprise la périnité
et la conséquence de la récurrence de
ces profits la récurrence de la
rentabilité et que la la récurrence de
cette rentabilité s'appuie sur la
compétitivité de l'entreprise elle-même
étant la conséquence de la performance
donc euh je dirais que tout débat qui
élud de la question fondamentale de la
performance et de la compétitivité
finalement n'est pas un débat sur le
cœur du problème une fois que cette
performance est assurée la compétitivité
on est la conséquence et du coup on peut
proposer à nos à nos clients euh des
produits attractifs au meilleur prix si
c'est rémunérateurs on pourra continuer
à réinvestir ses profits euh pour
l'avenir et à ce moment-là assurer la
pérénité de l'entreprise je m'excuse
d'avoir été plus long que prévu et je
suis donc à votre disposition pour les
questions merci Monsieur
Tavarez des questions de nos collègues
oui première
question oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur je vous félicite
pour l'accélération des nouvelles gammes
vous disiez dans votre propos que chaque
site industriel français a un avenir
assuré mais la question que je me pose
pourquoi le site de la Française de
Mécanique en en pascalé n'a pas été
retenu dans ce développement alors que
vous êtes Renault actionnaire à 50 % de
cette entreprise et que nous avons des
moteurs qui arrivent en fin de
vie d'autres
questions alors si s'il en a pas moi je
vais vous en poser une Monsieur le
Directeur euh voilà comme à votre
collègue de euh de PSA je faisais un peu
le point de des aides de l'État
concernant l'industrie
automobile vous rappelez quand il y a eu
cette fameuse crise épouvantable
financière l'État a ouvert la bourse et
a prêté 6,5 milliards d'euros de prêt
euh remboursé en 3 ans faut le dire avec
des intérêts à hauteur de 715 millions
d'euros il y a 900 millions de prêts qui
vont à au zoo
euh qui vont à l'industrie
automobile près de 2000 PME ont
bénéficié de de ces prêts
1,2 milliards de prime à la casse 2,3
milliards de bonus écologique vous en
parliez tout à l'heure çaajoute à cela
la la fin de la taxe professionnelle je
crois que ça représente une somme
importante pour Renault hein 315
millions de crédit impô recher pour à la
fois PSA et Renault c'est dire quand
même des sommes on est sur des sommes
très importantes alors la question que
je vais vous poser Monsieur le Directeur
elle est simple c'est c'est un
investissement massif de la nation et la
nation est en droit de vous demander
quels sont les emplois qui ont été avec
quelles sont les
relocalisations est-ce que les
délocalisations se poursuivent et la
balance du commerce extérieur
qui était auparavant largement
excédentaire avec nos deux constructeurs
vous savez que la depuis la Libération
la stratégie française industrielle
c'était d'aider des grands donneurs
d'ordre notamment comme Renault PSA mais
aussi dans l'aéronautique et tout cela
et on s'aperçoit maintenant que notre
commerce extérieur qui a qui connaît un
déficit habysal et bien est creusé y
compris par nos constructeurs parce que
pour la première fois depuis
2009 et bien nous avons 3,4 milliards en
ce qui concerne nos deux constructeurs
les les réimportations sur site alors la
question que je voudrais vous poser est
simple est-ce que vous pensez que le
fait de
produire en France ce que vous vendez
est juste j'ai regardé ça représente 18
à 20 % de votre production mondiale ce
que vous fabriquez en
France tout à l'heure votre concurrence
cétait environ c'est entre 34 et 38 %.
par contre euh Volkswagen c'est 55 %. il
y a chez nos collègues allement un
patriotisme profond industriel où certes
ils ont délocaliser certains produits
certaines pièces mais ils gardent ils
ont une volonté de garder euh des
process de fabrication fondamentaux sur
le territoire national et on on s'en
passage chez chez Renault vous m'excusez
et vous me démentirez euh
bien sûr je sens un peu une stratégie
surtout financière et pas assez
industrielle alors voilà les peut-être
une question un peu longue mais nous
sommes très inquiets de de des
stratégies qui sont mises en place ici
et là et qui font très très mal à nos
territoires parce que c'est les
territoires qui payent très cher et nous
avons un chômage record et tout à
l'heure vous disiez mais on n' pas fermé
de site simplement quand on connaît la
pyramide des âges et qu'on sait qu'il y
a un départ en retraite massif euh de du
du papibbom on sait très bien qu'avec
les départs les purs départs on peut
vider on peut vider des sites de
production voilà les questions monsieur
Tavarez en vous remerciant d'avoir ici
comment présenter la stratégie du groupe
mais je crois qu'il y a encore une
question
là-bas je vais donc écouter cette
question merci monsieur le Président les
consommateurs français sont dans une
stratégie de de lowost on le voit ils
peê des des voitures pas chères vous
avez évoqué la la marque d'cia hein qui
est une filiale de Renault j'ai constaté
la semaine dernière en baladant en
Bourgogne que la gendarmerie française
était aussi dans cette démarche parce
que j'ai vu des Dacia 44 roulé donc je
voulais savoir si quel était par exemple
le volume d'appel d'ofre de la
gendarmerie française vers cette marque
lowcast merci ah Monsieur Bertou oui
monsieur le directeur ma question va
au-delà de l'entrepreneur que vous êtes
de l'industriel que vous êtes mais
simplement votre
parcours au Japon aux États-Unis bien
entendu ici vous permet d'avoir un œil
en regard sur notre industrie et
lorsqu'on parle de la
désindustrialisation en
France qu'est-ce que vous pourriez faire
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez suggérer
comme idée quelles sont vos réflexions
précisément pour éviter que cette
désindustrialisation se
poursuive Monsieur le Directeur et bien
merci beaucoup pour pour ces quatre
questions je vais essayer d'y répondre
alors je vais je vais je va traiter dans
dans le désordre si vous me le permettez
d'abord je vais répondre à la question
sur la
gendarmerie en toute sincérité j'étais
pas informé de ce que vous avez dit mais
je n'ai pas de raison particulière de le
mettre en doute bien évidemment mais ça
ça veut dire quoi ça veut simplement
dire que dans dans le monde d'automobile
ce qui compte d'abord c'est la capacité
à répondre à un besoin au meilleur prix
et si vous on trouve des dashas dans la
gendarmerie nationale c'est sans doute
que les décideurs de la Gendarmerie
nationale ont considéré que ces
véhicules là pour le prix auquel nous
les vendions répondent répondent aux
besoins et finalement je crois que c'est
un bon exemple parce que personne ne
doutera du patriotisme de la gendarmerie
nationale et néanmoins alors que nous ne
doutons pas du patriotisme de la
gendarmie nationale ben la gendarmerie
achète ce qu'elle considère être le
produit adapté à ses besoins au meilleur
prix et et finalement tous les
consommateurs dans le monde entier y
compris les consommateurs français se
comportent de la sorte parce qu'ils ont
leurs propres contraintes et parce que
ils s'occupent de leur propre avenir et
et du confort et du bien-être de leur
famille donc le marché automobile est
ainsi fait que chaque consommateur va
prendre une décision en fonction des
critères qui lui sont propres évidemment
il sera lui-même en tant que salarié
touché dans telle ou telle entreprise
mais à titre individuel euh il va il va
prendre cette cette décision et alors
ceci me permet de basculer sur la votre
question monsieur le Président qui est
évidemment la question centrale je ne
veux pas être agressif et encore moins
arrogant euh par rapport à à à des
concurrents mais je trouve que s'il y a
quelque chose que nous puissions faire
pour la nation c'est d'abord d'assurer
la pérenité de cette entreprise et je
trouve que dans l'ordre des priorités la
première chose c'est de faire en sorte
que l'entreprise de bascule pas dans le
rouge que l'entreprise puisse continuer
à investir et qu'on n pas à mettre en
œuvre des plans sociaux simplement parce
que l'entreprise n'aura pas fait ou
n'aurait pas fait les bons choix et je
trouve que notre première responsabilité
la responsabilité fondamentale c'est
d'abord d'assurer la pérenité à partir
de là force de constater que tous nos
concurrents européens à l'exception de
Volkswagen et c'est un exemple notable
du groupe Volkswagen tous les
concurrents européens sont aujourd'hui
dans situation qui est une situation de
générer des pertes or nous savons que
nos sociétés et et les états n'auront
pas dans le proche avenir voir dans le
long terme ni la possibilité ni la
volonté de soutenir des entreprises qui
seront dans le rouge tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
financiers parce que si il devait le
faire ce serait le contribuable qui
devrait le payer or le contribuable
légitimement ne souhaite pas payer pour
ce que d'cun pourrait appeler des des
défauts de gestion des entreprises donc
autant je reçois 5 sur C votre question
que je trouve parfaitement légitime
autant je me dois de rappeler que le
rôle d'un dirigeant d'entreprise c'est
d'abord d'assurer la pérénité de
l'entreprise de protéger les
126000 salariés que nous avons sans
parler de leur famille des des
fournisseurs de la famille des des
fournisseurs et cetera et de faire en
sorte que cette entreprise fasse des
choix technologique qui soit pertinent
fasse des soix de stratégies
industrielles qui nous permettent de
nous battre contre nos concurrents voyez
il y a il y a un point qui qui me frappe
énormément et je crois que il est
important que qu'on le garde présent à
l'esprit le niveau de de discante en
Europe occidentale aujourd'hui dépasse
les 22 % autrement dit tous les
constructeurs européens avec des bases
industrielles en Europe discantent leur
véhicules euh probablement entre 20 et
30 %. or il est bien évident que si vous
regarder avant la crise ces
constructeurs là n'avaient pas des
marges opérationnelles ou des profit qui
leur permettaiit de disconter de 20 ou
30 % ils étaient à des marges de
quelques points de de pour donc il est
évident que avec ce niveau de discante
là ils vont conduire leurs entreprises
dans des situations extrêmement
difficiles et là on on ne parlera pas de
patriotisme industriel on on parlera de
chaos social tout simplement parce que
les entreprises ne pourront pas survivre
sauf si les états viennent combler le
trou ce qui se traduit par d'autres
formes de de drame que que nous nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons éviter à tout
instant alors peut-être que nous sommes
assez maladroit dans notre façon
d'exprimer notre patriotisme
industrielle mais je crois qu'il n'y a
rien de faux il n'y a rien de mauvais à
développer en France les technologies de
pointe à développer en France les
produits à forte valeur ajoutée les
véhicules utilitaires les véhicules
électriques les véhicules de haute gamme
et à considéré que pour que le le groupe
Renault puisse être rentable en France
pour le plus grand
bénéfice de nos salariés français je
trouve qu'il n'y a rien de mal à faire
du bon profit partout dans le monde pour
que l'entreprise dans son ensemble
restant profitable n'est pas à connaître
des situations dramatiques sur le sur le
plan humain et et franchement je je n'ai
pas mauvaise conscience je pense que
nous faisons ce qu'il faut pour que on
protège nos collaborateurs d'ailleurs
nos collaborateurs ils nous disent
parfois qu'on on leur demande beaucoup
et c'est vrai qu'on leur demande
beaucoup parce que nous sommes engagés
dans une concurrence mondiale qui était
freinée je voudrais vous rappeler une
chose assez simple c'est que les
meilleurs constructeurs mondiaux
aujourd'hui parmi les généralistes ne
font pas plus de 6 ou 7 points de marge
opérationnelle donc vous voyez que si
les meilleurs mondiaux font 6 ou 7 % dès
que vous commencez à désoptimiser votre
votre euh business global au sens où
vous mettez vos fabrications au sens où
quel produit vous faites quelle
technologie vous mettez en œuvre et à
quel prix vous allez les vendre vous
basculez très très vite dans le rouge et
donc ça c'est le drame que l'industrie
automobile est en train de connaître en
ce moment et autant nous sommes
extrêmement
reconnaissants à l'état français d'avoir
aidé l'entreprise pendant la première
crise autant nous sommes lucides sur le
fait que nous ne pourrons pas le
demander une deuxième fois parce que
l'État ne pourra pas nous aider une
deuxième fois dans ces proportions là ce
qui ne fait qu'accroître notre
responsabilité de garder l'entreprise
dans une bonne santé pour que on puisse
traverser cette tempête et et peut-être
derrière avir voir une croissance une
croissance qui soit encore plus visible
je finirai sur un point c'est que la
meilleure façon
d'aider le tissu industriel automobile
en Europe c'est d'abord de faire en
sorte que le marché européen s'améliore
et malheureusement ce sont des données
plutôt exogènes si le marché européen
comme conséquence de l'indice de
confiance des consommateurs ne
s'améliore pas la seule chose que moi je
puiss garantir d'un point de vue de
performance de l'entreprise c'est notre
part de marché une part un marché
raisonnable euh qui ne soit pas obtenu à
cûp de à coup de discante ce qui
évidemment est destructeur de valeur
donc voilà nous n'avons pas annoncé de
fermeture d'usine en France nous faisons
tout ce que nous pouvons pour que les
produits à forte valeur ajoutée soient
fait dans notre pays et nous sommes
prêts à défendre nos positions en 2011
je le rappelle nous avons été le la
deuxème marque européenne derrière
Volkswagen devant Ford nous avons été
les leaders en France et pour la 14e
année consécutif nous avons été les
leaders européens du véhicule du
véhicule utilitaire et nous avons battu
notre record de vente mondiale monsieur
le le directeur est-ce que vous pensez
que 18 à 20 % de production sur le sol
national est suffisant quand Volkswagen
est à 55 et PSA entre 34 et 38ors est-ce
que vous vous ne pensez pas que la la
réindustrialisation que nous appelons
tous de nos vœux vous devez y participer
et et y participer parce que non
seulement vous avez que pendant la crise
l'état vous AAZ aidé mais il continue à
aider énormément
l'état toutes ces politiques publiques
que sont le bonus écologique il y a eu
la prime à la case les prês de Zéo et et
la volonté d'aller vers la le véhicule
des carboné dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que vous devez intervenir plus sur le
sol français ça se fait en Allemagne ça
fonctionne pourquoi ne pas le faire chez
nous alors quand je dis ça c'est pas une
volonté que toute la production de
Renault se fasse en France mais 18 à 20
% reconnaissez que c'est vraiment trop
peu et quand vous prenez les véhicules
utilitaires qui sont dedans çadire c'est
l'ensemble des véhicules c'est vraiment
extrêmement peu et bien permettez-moi
monsieur le Président de de répondre et
et surtout de corriger de corriger un
point qui malheureusement n'est pas à
jour dans vos données c'est que ce ne
sont pas 18 % mais 25 % que nous
fabriquons en France et ça correspond à
peu de chos près en nombre au nombre de
véhicules que nous vendons en France
alors à la question faut-il participer
euh à une amélioration de compétitivité
qui nous permet d'en faire plus en
France la réponse est bien entendu oui
nous n'avons absolument pas aucun
problème avec ça bien au contraire
puisque de toute façon nous avons déjà
des capacités qui sont investies en
France donc nous n'avons aucun problème
avec ça simplement il faut se rendre
compte des batailles que nous avons à
remporter or ces batailles nous ne
pouvons pas les remporter tout seul euh
je vous ai donné tout à l'heure pour
éclairer votre votre réflexion euh le le
montant de l'écart entre une Clio 4 euh
venu qui vient de Turquie et une qui
vient de France c'est 1300 € c'est ça
l'ORD de grand mais vous demandez pas à
ce que les salariés français s'alignent
sur les salariés Turcs non c'est pas mon
point c'est pas oui mais justement on le
savait qu'il y avait une telle
différence entre les les salariés turcs
et des salariés français nous on pense
que cette protection sociale et ces
acquis sociaux c'est c'est un honneur
pour la France de les avoir et quand
vous faites une seconde usine Clio 4 à
en Turquie inévitablement la la
concurrence va être absolument déloyale
et le problème n'est pas de tirer la
France c'est d'amener le maximum
d'innovation en France parce qu'on sait
très bien que la productivité c'est pas
seulement le coût du travail c'est
essentiellement l'innovation dans les
techniques de production et et et cela
vous voyez y compris les salariés
français leur sentent très mal quand on
leur fait ce un peu ce chantage là en
disant vous êtes très cher alors que
vous disiez tout à l'heure que la
croissance française est en berne
justement parce que le pouvoir d'achat
n'augmente plus depis un certain temps
oui je pense que vous avez un propos un
peu réducteur parce que je ne crois pas
que l'automobile soit la seule industrie
de la société française donc veillons à
ne pas ramener tout à l'industrie
automobile et s'il vous plaît
n'entraînez pas Renault dans un débat de
société qui n'est pas le nôtre nous nous
ne voulons pas être les otages d'un
débat de société mais nous voulons
participer à l'amélioration des
conditions de vie de la société donc il
faut savoir sur le plan de la
compétitivité si on veut traiter un
problème de défaut de compétitivité à
l'intérieur de l' Europe ou entre
l'Europe et le reste du monde ça c'est
des questions que qu'on peut poser et
qui qui nous donneront les ordres de
grandeur des problèmes que nous allons
que nous avons à à traiter la question
de la compétitivité par rapport à
l'Allemagne c'est une très bonne
question je suis sûr que des gens plus
experts que moi vous expliqueraiz des
tas de choses sur ce que l'Allemagne a
fait ce que nous n'avons pas fait au
cours des des 10 ou 20 dernières années
mais c'est pas c'est pas mon propos
simplement moi je veux finir pour cet
élément de réponse qui peut-être ne vous
fera pas sur sur un point simple c'est
que la responsabilité première c'est la
périnité de l'entreprise c'est protéger
les personnes qui tous les jours tous
les jours sans exception contribu à ce
que l'entreprise soit ce qu'elle est euh
je pense que ça c'est c'est normal c'est
notre mission euh faire plus de voitures
en France c'est possible dès l'instant
que le marché euh augmente et je vous
rappelle que pour l'instant euh le
marché en 2011 il a été flat par rapport
à l'année précédente en 2012 il est
annoncé euh en en berne le marché
européen comme je vous l'ai montré sur
la courbe tout à l'heure il est il n'a
pas encore récupéré les niveaux de 2007
donc nous avons cette problématique et
et ce serait je pense injuste de faire
un procès à Renault sur le fait que le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et la
conséquence du fait que nous cherchons à
maintenir la compétitivité de
l'entreprise je pense ça ce serait pas
une accusation juste je pense que nous
sommes un acteur industriel qui apporte
beaucoup à la France qui certes est
désireux d'en apporter encore plus mais
pas au détriment de la pérenité de
l'entreprise parce que là encore si
demain Renault se mettait dans le rouge
et en situation deoir prendre des
décisions extrêmement douloureuses sur
le plan humain que diriez-vous des
dirigeants de l'entreprise que
diriez-vous de la stratégie de
l'entreprise qui l'a mise dans le rouge
et qu' a mise en situation de d'annoncer
des fermetures d'usine ce que nous
n'avons pas fait et voyez c'est ça qui
est un point assez étonnant vis-à-vis de
Renaud c'est que vous devriez au
contraire féliciter Renault vous devriez
féliciter Renault de tenir
vous devriez féliciter Renault d'avoir
une stratégie qui permet de maintenir
l'activité en France et d' d'attendre
que le marché européen s'améliore nous
ne sommes pas de ceux qui nous sommes
mis dans le rouge et nous ne sommes pas
de ceux qui avons annoncé des des des
plans sociaux donc je trouve que
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui j'étais pas
là pour prendre les décisions mais tous
ceux qui ont pris des décisions avant
moi vous êtes à la limite d'être un peu
injuste vis-à-vis des efforts qui sont
produits par l'entreprise mais j'accepte
le jeu puisque tel est le jeu et et je
je je je ne retire rien de ce que j'ai
dit je sais bien j'ai pas répondu à la
question sur sur la FM et voilà il y a
deux questions et puis aussi de Madame
lettard
aussi Valérie et puis vous répondrez aux
deux questions d'accord je ferai ça pard
je vous écoute merci
beaucoup je viens d'écouter avec
beaucoup d'attention votre démonstration
et et et on ne peut que reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui gérer une entreprise
telle que Renault dans un contexte
internationale complexe l'industrie de
l'automobile on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est certainement le secteur le plus
difficile en tout cas lorsqu'il faut
tenir le cap tenir le cap du maintien de
l'activité et du développement de
l'activité mais cette démonstration que
vous nous avez faite nous nous la
mettons en perspective des obligations
et des attentes qui sont celles d'élus
français d'élus français qui lorsqu'on
leur parle de Renault on leur parle
d'une entreprise française dont les
Français sont très fiers très fiers
effectiv qui vont pouvoir la préserver
de la garder et de la développer aussi
au service des salariés français et je
pense que l'équation qu'il nous faut
réussir aujourd'hui c'est faire en sorte
que l'attente qui est la nôtre en tant
que élus nationaux c'est de faire en
sorte que l'impact que l'industriel
Renault pourra avoir sur le
développement de notre propre activité
et le service rendu aux salariés aux
hommes et aux femmes qui vivent dans ce
pays et bien on puisse encore une fois
l'accompagner dynamiser ceci étant
j'entends bien ce que vous avez évoqué
mais euh en tant qu'élu territoriaux en
tant que élu devant s'investir et faire
des choix aussi en terme de stratégie de
développement industriel on se pose
cette question le débat c'est sur
l'industrie et comment nous on doit
accompagner ou pas accompagner cette
logique au service de nos population
parce que c'est aussi ça vous l'avez dit
préserver l'activité mais la développer
moi je suis élu d'un territoire je suis
président d'une aglo où l'industrie
automobile et ferroviaire c'est le socle
on est tellement convaincu de ça qu'on
en a fait notre priorité straté strégque
en terme de développement de notre
territoire et d'accompagnement par notre
aglo de la dynamique industrielle on met
le paquet on porte un cluster avec une
université qui met le paquet sur
l'accompagnement de la Red de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche dans le domaine de
l'automobile et du ferroviaire on y met
nous beaucoup de moyens pour y mettre de
l'activité accueillir des entreprises de
RD tout ce qui peut concourir à gagner
de la valeur ajoutée à faire en sorte
que les industriels trouvent les
ressources humain mais aussi la capacité
à chercher à être meilleur avoir la
valeur ajoutée que vous dites maintenant
moi la question que je me pose quand je
vous entends c'est comment et est-ce
qu'il faut continuer ces cet effort là
et est-ce que lorsqu'on fera cet effort
de RD qu'on essaie de travailler le plus
possible avec les industriels présents
sur le territoire combien de temps et
dans quelle proportion cet effort de RD
impactera sur le maintien d'une activité
industrielle sur le territoire quelle
part c'estàdire demain effectivement ce
travail sur ces pôles de recherche qui
se développe fortement qu'on met en
place qu'est-ce que ça va générer comme
type d'activité développement industriel
ce sera une boîte de vitesse ce sera
j'en sais rien telle ou telle partie à
forte valeur ajoutée pour des véhicules
hybrides ou électriques mais pendant
combien de temps on maintient ça est-ce
que c effort ça veut dire qu'on va
produire par exemple une boîte de
vitesse et combien de temps on va la
produire là et à partir de combien de
temps de quel délai on va prendre cette
technologie et aller la produire
ailleurs ce que je dire c'est que nous
on fait le pari effectivement d'être
toujours un temps en avance mais dans
quelle proportion cet effort que nous
consentons sur le territoire aura une
répercussion et un impact dans le
maintien de l'activité industrielle sur
notre territoire c'est pas un piège que
je vous pose c'est juste que nous on est
en train de faire des choix politiques
lourd territoriaux et nationaux dans
quelle mesure et dans quelle proportion
ils vont impacter positivement sur ce
que vous dites c'est-à-dire être capable
d'avoir un segment à forte valeur ajouté
dans tous les champs et et est-ce qu'on
fait le bon paril ou est-ce que
l'industrie est définitivement condamné
en tout cas en terme d'activité de masse
vraiment socle de notre de
notre potentiel de développement
d'emploi ou ou pas quoi j'ai besoin de
de de de comprendre ce que vous exposez
c'estd est-ce qu'on a raison de miser
sur ça et dans quelle proportion ça
impactera sur votre changement de
comportement en tout cas sur le segment
que vous pouvezê vous seriez en capacité
de produire demain merci Valérie en
sachance ce que Valérie cette
closurisation des territoires ça se fait
dans dans plusieurs endroits et les
collectivités territoriales investissent
beaucoup mais effectivement monsieur
tavarz ce qui est important c'est que on
l'a posé tout à l'heure à à l'autre
société qui était avant vous est-ce
qu'on a des signaux importants de
réindustrialisation de relocalisation
pour que ces investissements extrêmement
lourds des collectivités territoriales
soient accompagnés par nos grands
industriels très bien je vais je vais
d'abord par courtoisie répondre à la
question sur sur la FM euh pour vous
dire deux choses d'abord c'est le
l'avenir de la FM est une responsabilité
partagée avec PSA ce n'est pas qu'une
responsabilité Renault deuxièmement vous
dire que comme vous le savez
actuellement on produit le moteur d euh
mais que nous avons nous Renault déjà
pris la décision de fabriquer dans cette
rusine des éléments de la chaîne de
traction du véhicule électrique euh donc
nous serons un peu plus précis dans dans
quelques temps mais nous prenons euh de
notre côté nos responsabilités dans dans
ce domaine donc je ne crois pas que ce
site soit soit soit en risque mais je
conçois que face à l'avalanche d'annonce
que nous avons fait ces derniers temps
chacun se demande et moi et moi et moi
et bien ça ça viendra en en en son temps
euh j'ai donné l'exemple de Cléon parce
que Cléon est une une de nos usines en
France qui tourne à pleine activité
parce qu'elle a su préserver justement
la compétitivité de des produits qu'elle
fabrique j'en viens à votre question
stratégique et je mesure à quel point
votre votre mission est difficile elle
elle n'est jamais aussi difficile que la
mienne c'est-à-dire que euh j'ai aussi
devant moi beaucoup de gens qui me
demandent des certitudes or des
certitudes j'en ai pas la seule
certitude que j'ai c'est que nous sommes
dans une industrie automobile qui est
impitoyable qui est ouverte et nous
avons créé nous nous tous ensemble les
conditions d'une
concurrence qu'on pourrait qualifier de
sanguinaire parce que avoir un tel
niveau de surcapacité sur un marché
décroissant c'est la certitude d'avoir
une une une décroissance une destruction
de valeur importante comme je vous l'ai
dit par les mécanismes que je vous ai
et ces mécanismes sont assez pervers
c'est que plus vous avez une structure
importante une surcapacité importante
plus vous avez la pression pour vendre
plus simplement pour diluer vos frais
fixes pour faire tourner vos usines et
plus vous vendez plus dans de mauvaises
conditions plus vous perdez de l'argent
et puis vous ne faites que augmenter la
taille de la bulle qui à un moment ou un
autre vous éclate à la figure et et
c'est ce qui immanquablement se produira
sur certains constructeurs européens
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas continuer à
vendre dans des ces conditions là alors
qu'ils ont des structures qui
manifestement sont trop importantes donc
c'est pour ça que nous veillons à ce que
il y ait un bon équilibre entre nos
frais fixes et la rentabilité de nos
ventes unitaires sur les STR
stratégiques que que vous mentionnez
nous on a pris nos responsabilités on a
investi à Cléon le moteur de nouvelle
génération des véhicules électriques on
a on va investir à Flin une usine de
batterie on a investi dans quatre
véhicules électriques différents
dont deux sont produits en France et on
a décidé de relocaliser le Renault
traffic dans notre usine de Sandouville
donc là encore pour revenir sur notre
discussion avec le président à un
instant quand je sais leseff que tout
ceci représente à l'inne dans
l'entreprise je trouve que vraiment
c'est assez difficile pour les salariés
de Renault d'être critiqué sur ce que
vous auriez appelé un manque de de
patriotisme industriel je pense que nous
nous nous montrons nous montrons par nos
décisions parfois audacieux
à quel point nous remettons des
investissements en France 40 % de nos
investissements sont faits en France
alors que seul 25 % de nos volumes sont
vendus en France ça représente beaucoup
d'argent 8
milliards au cours des derniers années
40 % des investissements donc si vous me
demandez est-ce que cette technologie
est les pérenes je ne sais pas il peut y
avoir une révolution technologique qui
fait que la technologie d'aujourd'hui
dans 10 ans elle va changer et c'est
peut-être les les Chinois ou les
Américains qui vont faire la rupture sur
une autre technologie et c'est pour ça
qu'il est important de continuer à
investir sur la Red et c'est ce que nous
faisons et l'axe que vous avez décrit me
paraître un bon axe il y en a un autre
sur lequel moi je je me permettrai de
faire un commentaire c'est laisser les
Libert la liberté aux entreprises de
respirer laisser aux entreprises la
possibilité de s'adapter à leur
environnement parce que lorsque l'on
crée un carcan qui empêche aux
entreprises de s'ajuster par par petit
pas à un changement d'environnement et
bien si vous bloquez le système
l'environnement lui de toute façon il
change et empêcher une entreprise de
respirer c'est simplement reporter à
plus tard la le problème à résoudre qui
de toute façon ne fera que croître dans
le temps donc donner aux entreprises
françaises la possibilité de s'adapter
leur environnement est un facteur de
compétitivité à moyen et long terme
parce que si vous vous empêchez de
bouger et bien vous vous empêchez de
s'adapter si elle s'adapte elle s'adapte
pas c'est comme les dinosaures elles
disparaissent donc c'est important de
d'avoir cette flexibilité mais
l'investissement dans la RD c'est un
investissement qui est je pense un bon
investissement il est sain sur le fond
euh comme je sais que vous êtes d'une
région où nous n'avons pas d'usine je
pense que vous devriez poser la question
à Toyota et à et à et à PSA et et et
comme vous savez je vous ferai pas
l'injure de vous rappeler que Toyota n'a
pas sa RD en France he ils ont leur RD
au Japon donc donc voilà voilà ce que je
peux vous dire mais RD c'est c'est un
bon choix vous savez il y a beaucoup de
gens qui nous parlent de la volatilité
malheureusement on est dans un monde de
volatilité on nous demande tout le monde
demande des prévisions je pense que la
volatilité a atteint un niveau qui fait
que les prévisions sont maintenant sans
sans sans sens elles ont perdu leur sens
nous sommes dans un contexte où il faut
créer l'avenir plutôt que de le prévoir
et et et donc il faut être déterminé par
rapport à ce que vous voulez faire et
nous ce que nous voulons faire c'est
faire en sorte que la récurrence de la
rentabilité de notre entreprise en sur
la
pérénité merci Monsieur le Directeur je
crois que on a dépassé de 20 minutes euh
désolé ben écoutez le débat était
passionnant était passionnant voilà nous
vous remercions pour cette merci à vous
de m'avoir écouté
merci voilà pour ces deux auditions
consacrées à l'avenir de l'industrie
automobile pour les revoir notre site
internet
publsena.fr bonne journée à
tous